[Music]
it's
so
[Music]
now
uh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
now
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong
but i
[Music]
is eyes for your
it eyes
think about it later
[Music]
think about
think about it
i don't care
[Music]
is
[Applause]
for your lips
[Music]
think about it later
is
[Music]
as the world ended an unprecedented
crisis magnus carlson and chess 24 acted
quickly to create the first online chess
tour of his kind working 24 7 we brought
together the best players in the world
for the largest online prize fund ever
broadcast live in 10 languages the tour
innovated and filled the void created by
the lack of in-person play reaching more
people than any online chess event ever
there was fun and laughter
okay it's time for russian hackers to
attack
internet
[Music]
last hope
there was tension and controversy
yeah
and then give up the phone
this is hopeless unish is fast these
days
okay so
we will have a fantastic match tomorrow
i'm sure
jan is angry as hell now
but any shows support his written so
let's see
there were instructive learning moments
we have discovered
e6 was a very strong move for nepali as
she opens up the diagonal of the queen
and at the same time shots out the d5
bishop from the defense black has to
play rookie seven to protect the popcorn
and the seventh rank but now the queen
comes from the f5 queen f2 threatening
rook have seven and its curtains so the
position is collapsing right now here
black has to resign and there was lots
of great chairs
oh wow wow it's really
an incredible game like showing how a
completely lost position
can gradually turn into a winning
position if you just trade all the right
pieces it's really this game is really a
master class on on the trades what you
should be trading and what not and when
i said that
trading the queens and the bishops uh is
good for black i never imagined it would
ever happen because it's just it was so
far away from that wow and it's official
resignation from dingley four unique
online events and a grand final made up
the magnus carlson chess tour and the
world took notice
[Music]
the magnus carlsen chess tour has been
the most watched online chess event in
history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments as the first season
approaches its conclusion we want your
help to do something even bigger our
partner for the tour final is kiva the
non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help underserved
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
that means magnus carlton wins the rapid
tape break and keeps his title as world
champion
congratulations and happy birthday to
magnus carlsen
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so i would say that uh somehow my
experiences with math have really shaped
with my experiences in chess i would say
you know early on the thing that first
drew me to chess was uh
trying to analyze sort of simple end
games and come to a definite conclusion
about a position something that's sort
of
very much a mathematical type pursuit
and i would say that one thing that
chess has sort of given me is that over
time i've come to really
appreciate sort of uncertainty and
trying to sort of
make sense of you know things that are
quite complicated and quite uh
sort of non-intuitive i mean chess is
you know such a
simple game in many ways you know
there's not too many pieces
the rules aren't too complicated but
somehow you get this great complexity
[Music]
hello and welcome to chess 24 this is
the magnus carlsen chess stop benefiting
kiva final and i am pumped to be here
today and get the action started because
what we witnessed on day one of the
finals it made it really clear ladies
and gentlemen that we've got a real
fight a real match on our hands
and hikaru nakamura was the one who
wrote to victory in that first set in
convincing style beating magnus carlsen
two and a half to one and a half it
reminded me of that tweet that hikaru
had up before starting the finals and uh
let's see if we can get that up because
i think
this tweet aged rather well because take
a look at what it said and uh let's play
it
there he is
came out off the fire right into victory
but of course um
it's uh
it was not easy but but hikaru nakamura
was up to the task and i think it was
brilliant to see just the kind of prep
he had going just how quickly he was
playing his confidence everything fell
into place for the american grand master
what was really insightful was also what
the players had to say about each other
going into the finals take a look at
hikaru stake towards the final
butcher are you you've got two two days
now before uh before the finals are you
already assuming that
you're going to be up against magnus or
going to wait for the final result or
will prep begin soon
yeah you know i i mean to get back to
that point i was making earlier and this
i think is is again a style stylistic
thing is is what i was saying is that i
feel for the most part i'm more accurate
than most players and i defend extremely
well um and and the reason that i have
the issues with magnets or at least i've
had the issues in these online events
very specifically is because magnus is
slightly better at defending slightly
better pressing end game so this is very
slight margin when you're playing at
someone who's slightly who does these
things i mean i wouldn't even say
there's a big difference but he does all
these little things slightly better
that's when you kind of have to start
mixing up with the style and playing
differently so i'll be doing i'll be
doing some some research and checking
out but i'm going to assume magnus will
win because
some insights by the by the american
grandmaster five-time us champion about
facing magnus carlsen also
very interesting what magnus had to say
about
taking on hikaru nakamura in
his a game and with the kind of shape
that we've been seeing hikaru in take a
look at what magnus said about it and
what are your thoughts on meeting hikaru
in the finals from our perspective it
looks like the two most deserving
players have made it into the finals
yeah certainly uh he's been very very
strong in in the entire tour
so it's it's no coincidence that he's in
the final and uh i absolutely agree that
uh he he deserves it based on the way
that he
is
he's white
and that definitely set the tone for the
finals and what a show by hikaru in set
one but i think it's really critical
what he said after winning that winning
the game yes winning his set yesterday
that at the end of it this is just the
first set in a best of seven so the
players are playing a best of seven
format which means it's you've got to
win at lea you've got to win four sets
to win the finals so still a long
path ahead and uh it's just getting
started but pretty much a dream start
for hikaru because up against the world
champion if you are going to be the one
playing catch up once things get rolling
it's
it's not going to be easy but right now
it's magnus who's up to the wall who's
got to level the score a big day for him
really because i think if you fall back
on two sets
that is an absolute nightmare to come
from and if all the chess and the
intense on-board action that we have
been having has inspired you to improve
your game then you've got to check out
the hottest drop in the chess world
right now which is magnus carlsen's
course on endgames on chessable it's
live and you've got to go to
trustable.com and you've got to take a
look it's the magnus touch on endgames
where magnus gives us his insights on
what it takes to be a pro ending player
check this out
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracies yeah years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
[Music]
an extremely instructive and a mega
entertaining course by perhaps one of
the best end game players of all times
the world champion magnus carlsen but
right now magnus's task is cut up for
him he needs to level the score because
i do not believe if he's playing a two
match catch up a two set catch up to
hikaru nakamura he will be able to do
that so he needs to strike and strike
back today because these guys are
fighting for big bucks take a look at
the prices the winner goes back with a
hundred and
forty thousand dollar while
the loser of the finals is at least
secured with eighty thousand dollars as
a that's a very big 60k jump in that
definitely big money to fight for and
for hikaru especially
it's also
if he wins the final not only does he
win the final of the most prestigious
chess event of 2020 but he will do that
by beating the world champion a lot too
a lot to play for there and of course
magnus carlsen we know him he knows how
to bring his best he is so competitive
he knows how to go back there and win in
situations and make that ever critical
come back we saw him do exactly that in
his semi-final match against dinglarin
when he actually fell back at the
beginning and lost the set one but came
back with a three set victory
back to back that was very impressive so
if anybody can do that it is the world
champion and as hikaru said it himself
it's far from over right now but what a
start we have and like i was saying
we've got a real match on our hands and
of course let's take a look at what you
had to say about the intense action that
took place yesterday on our day one of
the finals let's get up the
conversations that we had on twitter's
fair uh
carsten hanson writing in with well done
to nakamura taking the first set against
magnus today magnus seemed a bit off not
making the best of his chances and
struggling throughout it will be
interesting to see if tomorrow brings
magnus 2.0 to the table as we saw in the
dingler and match indeed he was he was
one set down came back to beat ding he
needs to do that today he needs to come
back in his a game in shape and you are
absolutely right carsten that i felt
that as well that what we saw yesterday
was a magnus who felt who looked at
least extremely exhausted the mental
fatigue i feel you could see on his face
and it's been a grueling difficult
format for the world champion who's had
absolutely no rest as they say no rest
for the wicked and i think magnus has
been on it
definitely the kind of positions that we
saw yesterday it was it just felt like
hikaru was handling them better and uh
madness never really got into his rhythm
let's move on to the next one
[Music]
we heard from dread wow hikaru has
really come out hot against magnus
carlsen in the impact chess finals today
it was just incredible i think i think
more surprising than the actual result
of the set yesterday was just the play
that happened
it was very clear to all of us that the
level of play was so high from hikaru
nakamura that not only did he win the
set but he basically dominated the set
he was also very close to winning in
that game three and game four i think
was the only one where magnus was able
to draw some chances but even that
hikaru held on and showed that if it
comes to defending difficult positions
he's up to the task and it brings back
is brings back the point that this is a
very in shape hikaru in a format that
suits him incredibly well let's move on
we also had chess files writing in
hikaru came out guns blazing today
indeed and i think um
uh yes he's got to do that today as well
because at the end of it you can't stop
with the world champion you give him one
chance you give magnus one chance to
come on top and he will grab it and how
set one well done for hikaru but he
cannot relax just yet far from it and it
was in it was amazing to see the kind of
support and the kind of messages that
were out there for hikaru and uh and
also for magnus hoping for a comeback
really quick let's move on to our next
tweet we heard from
from grandmaster ivan writing in with
well deserved win by naka we are in for
an exciting showdown when the going gets
tough the tough gets going we cannot
wait for tomorrow time
indeed i think definitely a very
deserving win by naka you cannot say he
got lucky in in yesterday's set and i
think in general in chess you make your
own luck on the board so uh he just
played such energetic combative chess
from the word go and made it very clear
that he's not afraid to take on the
world champion in diff in difficult
complex positions we are definitely in
for a very thrilling final and it's just
gotten started let's move on to the next
one
and mr dodgy has got magnus carlsen's
back don't worry maxie i will save you
um yes um
maggie boggs needs all the saving that
he can get right now i think most most
importantly for magnus it's going to be
the strategy change that he has coming
into today's match and just how much
energy he can get in and hopefully the
world champ got enough rest after the
tough day yesterday because we all know
that despite being a set down i think
magnus is still a favorite in this match
i think uh
i think we all believe in his ability to
come back but man is hikaru in beast
mode right now let's move on to the next
one we also had
olympia writing in with magnus carlsen
loses a critical game and i think in
this
i think what was really interesting
was to see just the pain that and the
difficulty that magnus was having
yesterday in his match let's play this
shot video that we had and we can just
see this was i think after his loss
in game two
and
yes a very uh
he knows that he knows that it was just
all hikaru in that game and it almost
for me i just i just really felt that
this was a very very exhausted magnus
and i think the format is taking its
toll but the world champion has shown
that he's got it in him to come out of
it and i have no doubt that the match is
far from over let's move on to the next
one
with pratik writing in getting magnus
getting in time trouble very much lately
does he need to play faster change his
game a bit this i think is a very
insightful point because we have seen
magnus throughout the store and
throughout his matches against other
players he's always been up on the clock
he's always had the clock situation in
control but yesterday i think hikaru's
opening prep and his entire approach
worked so well and he was playing fast
and i think this is an insight that
hikaru gave us after the match that you
know the whole aim of just getting as
messy
a position that he could get and then
just making making
decent good moves not looking for the
best move not burning the clock uh and
playing quickly and yesterday i think
for the very first time on the tour very
rarely we've seen this that magnus game
after game fell short on the clock let's
move on we also had
edward writing in
we also had edward writing in uh magnus
carlson needs better time management and
perhaps to steer clear of sharp
positions to level the score with hikaru
in today's impact chess you know edward
this yes we just spoke about the whole
situation of the time thing i think when
magnus is feeling a little out of shape
and a little out of rhythm and not
himself on a particular day we've seen
him sort of burn
burn the time on his clock a little bit
you know we see him hesitating before
going for lines we see him taking a
little bit longer before he makes those
decisions and that's exactly what
happened yesterday and what you're
saying about the kind of positions that
he needs to play against tekaru very
interesting because i would agree with
that i think we saw that in game four
that when magnus got
you know the sort of position where he
really thrives in i mean he's a
universal player but when he got the
position where i think he plays he plays
unbelievably well slightly quiet just
building something out of nothing and
that's what we saw in game four where he
got his chances and the only game where
hikaru nakamura was on the back foot and
i think this inside by hikaru that i
think magnus was trying to play the way
he's played throughout the last two
events which is he's tried to play sharp
aggressive with both colors and i think
the positions are slightly more suited
to me um edward i think this really
reflects on what your insight was on the
whole thing as well that perhaps the
approach
has to be a little different maybe not
as many night offs we're going to see
today uh perhaps you're going to see
something a little more solid today and
who better to talk about that than our
commentators because i see we are being
joined by grand master yasser ceremony
and grandmaster peter leckel let's get
them on board hi ass hi peter hello
tanya hello everyone it's a pleasure to
be with you i to be here and to call the
finals of the magnus carlson tour peter
uh we're having too much fun together
but i'm really happy to see that you're
on the other side of the broadcast
yeah absolutely thank you yasir thank
you tanya it's it's great to be here it
has been a wonderful first day my big
question is how much did he call reveal
from his strategy point uh in the first
day yeah because he has given so much
uh energy into this very first set and
he has won it absolutely deservedly but
it kind of also give a lot of lot of
insight to to team magnus what to expect
from hikaru and now the big question is
how magnus will adjust his his play
against this strategy so i can't really
wait to see this game and i'm very happy
that magnus has the white pieces in the
first game so
what do we see do we see some really
aggressive magnus jumping at hikaru
right from the first game or will he
take a slower approach just as he did in
the last game yesterday
peter i think that's super insightful
because you're completely right that
hikaru with his play yesterday the kind
of openings he came up with uh just his
attitude of playing the most risky the
most sharp variations on the board made
his approach really clear made the prep
for this match really clear by his team
that these are the positions we're
aiming for a complete mess on the board
and then just trying to play fast making
decent moves making good moves not
burning up the clock not looking for the
best moves and i think this was also
reflected in hikaru's interview later
you're completely right about a lot of
information now that team magnus has and
how are they going to build on that
because whatever their approach for ma
set one was
that failed so they've got to bring on
big changes and i want to ask uh both
you and
yes that
in this in the in this entire final
magnus has played five sets he's won
three he lost two hikaru nakamura has
played four sets so far including the
semi-finals and the finals he's won all
four sets
of course in any in any match-up that
these two have magnus is a big favorite
but right now
is hikaru
the better player because of all the
factors of you know being more fresh is
he is he more in shape
is has he been more impressive than
magnus in this final including the semis
so far
what can you say about perfection tanya
playing four sets and winning them all
well you gotta say
that is a very very hot player indeed
yesterday i saw the set as being
quite close remember it was that pivotal
game too and tanya you yourself pointed
out that if magnus had found the move d4
d5 at a crucial moment we might be
talking a different
uh
ball game altogether but yes there was a
lot of information that was provided in
the first set you know for what i think
is a kind of a mira marathon finals
seven sets lots and lots and lots of
games it sure feels peter like we all
learned a lot and i see the players are
on cameras they're getting ready to
start uh today's session but peter your
take
yeah i mean looking at the statistics
yeah hikaru did win four out of four so
far in the finals but you know as a
player i always felt like i want to play
such player who has a perfect score
because i mean every streak has to end
at some point and
you really feel that okay i mean it
can't go on forever like this
besides okay one can argue that uh
magnus also had the very very tough
pairing with with dingley ram because i
mean all respect for for daniel duboff
he's an incredible uh powerful and very
energetic talented player but i mean
tingling has this super class he has
been like top three for already many
many years he had proven himself already
to be very unpleasant for magnus so all
in all maybe magnus had little tougher
challenge there but before getting into
all this we already have the action
there magnus started with d4
[Music]
indeed and who can forget the 19 match
winning streak that magnus himself had
throughout the tour before he lost to
ding and we've got action very similar
to what happened yesterday yes peter
take us through what's going on
absolutely uh peter a repeat of the
game
three no game a pardon me it's a repeat
of uh game two
yeah yeah repeat of game two and i feel
like maybe not hikaru but his team is
listening to us yeah
you remember you told about this
prophylactic move queen d7 you did not
like kicking the knight away from from
b5 with the move a6 and he karuna played
this very subtle queen d7 move this is
somehow i feel very much uh yasser
yeah it it it suits the position a lot
more but
also the first player to
change or deviate
was magnus because he came up with a2 a3
as you already call peter and we were
guessing that this might have been
preparation from london for his match
with fabiano fabiano having introduced
this line with b5 uh
in in top level play so uh
magnus's a284 was he was the first to
deviate peter
yeah but i mean you know i i'm
completely speechless i even don't know
where to start because i believe that
this whole a4 sequence from magnus was
supposed to be a surprise and look what
i mean
the players are blitzing out moves and
right now this is our current position i
mean
this is some
incredible deep preparation by both
sides and i believe that uh
yeah the teams have been working uh all
night to to make sure that they are
getting more and more ready for this
variation
it sure looks like uh the teams are
really burning the midnight oil as
you're saying because if you don't mind
going through it at some point these
players are going to slow down right now
magnus has 17 minutes hikaru 16 they
both started with 15 they are getting a
10 second bonus for each move they made
but this is remarkable uh
peter i i it almost looks like they're
playing a three-minute blitz game and
not a rapid game so if you don't mind
just take it
from i don't know the top or wherever it
is you'd like to start a4 good play okay
let's start right from the beginning
because those who have missed the action
yesterday
first of all it was a big miss secondly
okay it can happen so let's just uh
understand how we got there
uh so we are seeing it starts like a
vienna variation but after e4 b5 it very
much goes into
directions queen's gambit accepted i
mean the structure after e5 knight b5
knight xb5 knight b6 resembles much more
the queen's gambit accepted and here
magnus came up with this new move i
don't know if it's completely new but
definitely compared to yesterday where
we have seen the movie ac which was also
very interesting so this time a4 and the
move yasser was mentioning yeah in
yesterday's broadcast that he very much
likes this prophylactic move queen d7 of
course not in this position but in these
type of positions hikaru's team was
listening queen d7 had been played
bishop e2 developing knight c6 castles
knight e5 you again see the same
idea from black in bringing the knight
to a5 protecting the pawn on c4 and
eyeing the weakness on b3 just as
yesterday with the pawn on a3 magnus
goes
right for for action i mean he has to
justify his slightly weakened a4 move he
goes for action with knight g5 h6 knight
e4 bishop b7 all kind of very natural
knight c5 bishop takes c5 dtx e5 it's a
transformation of structure and that's
why i've it i felt like i had to mention
this immediately that i mean without
preparation such decisions you would be
taking after in a classical game like 20
minutes or half an hour of swords but
here everything had been blizzed out of
tempo which is a clear indication that
it had to be preparation and now after
knight d5 we see uh one of the bigger
sets of white putting the pawn on a4
that suddenly the white hook
activates itself on the third rank with
rook a3 he called one played a6 knight
d4 had been played and this was maybe
the first moment when hikaru took his
first time like maybe one minute or one
and a half minute and played the very
nice flexible move knight e7
and after 97 magnus quite quickly played
queen d2 just to indicate that yes you
know i'm very very prepared i'm taking
this match extremely seriously i'm ready
for everything
wow uh kind of an echo of the queen d7
well first of all i'd like to say
that i find myself
more drawn to this
middle game than i did yesterday's
middle game yesterday's middle game
peter um
magnus has put his bishop on c1 to e3
and he at the time he did it it was fine
there was no problem but the bishop e3
was kind of a useless piece it didn't
really be
participate here the bishop on c1
it's fine
but more importantly it doesn't obstruct
the path for the rook the rook is
definitely definitely destined for the
g3 and so i just feel that that somehow
magnus uh has uh a free or easier game
than he did yesterday whether it gives
him a big advantage or any kind of
advantage we still don't know the jury's
out but you like the move 97 and go
ahead and talk
to our audience about that what do you
find in particular that's so attractive
yeah i think the whole point was that as
already yesterday we kind of mentioned
these positions that the d5 square is
very very nice black wants to have the
d5 square but whenever you place
something on d5 something is missing out
of the position now we see the knight on
d5 is wonderful but suddenly the bishop
on b7s long diagonal is blocked on the
other hand white's knight on d4 is
slightly loose i mean it would be very
nice to target it because it's not
really clear where this knight gonna
move so once we have all this in mind
then the move97 comes very naturally it
opens the long diagonal for the bishop
it gives the way for the blackrook to
join the action along the d-file
putting pressure on the d4 knight and
also this knight on e7 might go to f5
later once the knights on d4 had been
clarified or the knight can go to g6
putting some extra defense on the
on the king side so it's a very flexible
move and magnus says yeah before you get
all these ideas in before you hit my
knight on d4 i want to touch your knight
on a5 and please show me how you're
gonna react to that
because uh after all if this knight from
e5 moves then the pawn on c4 can fall on
the other hand this is also not a
completely devastating sequence because
uh if black exchanges this knight even
if he loses this pawn on c4 he might
have some very nice play along the on
the wide squares
but okay in order to lose a pawn or to
be ready to
give up the pawn you have to first
understand that you definitely have
enough because if you just lose the pump
for nothing that would be terrible
exactly so now queen d2 uh as you say
the the knight on d4 is a little bit
loose the move queen d2 doesn't uh
prepare rook f1 to d1 trying to control
the open d file and of course uh black
is always to
realize that queen takes a5 queen takes
d4 queen takes c7 may come at the cost
of a pawn so i definitely
see this move queen d2 as a direct
threat to the night
uh how to deal with it uh peter should
we castle long which really looks uh
suicidal or do we just have to
uh
retreat our night
well i mean i think we are being clever
enough to ask this question at this
moment because
we already have the answer yeah
d5 had been played and uh it's a very
very natural move of course because also
quite nice feeling to make such move you
feel like
my opponent had attacked the knight on
a5 and instead of dealing with that i
suddenly threatened checkmate in one and
also eyeing the pawn on c5 so if for
example why just reacts in a very
natural way with bishop fc then black
can probably simply take the pawn on c5
protecting the knight
with the with the queen
and also the light square bishop
exchange would be in black's favor so
this would be a very nice scenario if
black is not losing immediately and i
don't see why he should be losing
and having this in mind then the big
question is how to deal with this
because it might look like okay take g2
mate this is one moves that i will deal
with it but every move um has some
concession for example the most natural
move to me looks like look gc without
calculating anything because i protect
and attack on the other hand i'm not
sure that this is this is exactly what
white wants to place the immediately on
g3
okay and just go ahead and continue this
line because like you say uh one of my
absolutely absolutely favorite moves to
make my favorite move to make of course
is checkmate my second favorite is to
win tempe and my third favorite is to
make those moves that are both offensive
and defensive and i love this move rook
g3 from that uh perspective but there is
a uh
how do you say uh
something very forcing in the position
to calculate like
maybe queen takes c5 to defend the the
night and to prepare castling long
yeah i mean this long castle is really
annoying because if it comes it comes
with a devastating effect it's unpinned
on the d file and then also some jump
like knight f5
might occur that's exactly the reason
why i was saying that yes it looks like
look gc is so natural and tempting but
i'm not sure
if this is exactly the
the way i want to treat the position
it's it's also very difficult to to see
anything after queen d5 because
uh basically it's the typical scenario
that if you are following some computer
preparation
and then
you really want to know the follow-up
because
everything makes sense if you know the
follow-up if you don't know then it
might look like why did i make any of
these moves yeah and uh now that magnus
is taking his time okay he had the time
advantage he was up fighting like five
minutes on the clock so he is not taking
his time absolutely
correctly because uh this is maybe a
very very important decision now
yes exactly that's a
indeed that's the way i see it and i
noticed that in a number of our
broadcast peter you've been referring to
the idea that oh this is great computer
analysis computer prep
and then also
a warning to our
uh audience that don't just blindly
follow the computer's recommendation
rather try to understand exactly why
you're putting your piece on a3 the rook
goes to a3 goes to g3 that's
understandable but there's also times
that you don't want to you're
necessarily to go to g3 maybe you want
to go to f3 so try to understand the
ideas behind the moves uh not just the
moves themselves uh i wanted to well i
don't know if this is the the
i see
a large number of tactics occurring in
the position okay
so one tactic i'm seeing is i really
don't like playing for let's say rook g3
queen takes c5 b4 ideas that i don't
find those
that that to be particularly attractive
because i think that it's helping black
more than it's helping white but i need
to move the queen yes exactly i need to
move the queen off of the
d file uh peter so i'm thinking rook g3
queen take c5
queen f4 and the idea behind this queen
f4
is i got some tactic with
knight if rook knight g6 i got some
tactic with e6 i was thinking
uh would be uh
would be uh a challenge yeah something
of this nature so i'm not saying that g6
is forced but i think queen f4 is
necessary to get off the d-file and to
kind of keep the knight on a5 so if i
look at it as a pawn sacrifice i say
well my trump
is the knight is offside on a5 and i
have a very aggressive rook so
so
if we could go back to the move queen f4
for a moment
and in my mind i'm thinking okay i put
my queen on f4 black ever tries to
castle long i got moves like you know
bishop e3 and queen f7 that he'll have
to deal
he could never ever castle short because
i don't know i just gonna go like rook
g7 and queen h6 and you know happily
mate the guy
so i'm seeing the position after queen
f4 as being you know super
uh
as well i mean it seems like this whole
match starting from yesterday at least
has
really uh
focused on very razor sharp positions
the players are really challenging one
another to come up with the best moves
each and every turn
yeah but uh to be honest if
we think like this then uh maybe this
plays again into hands off of hikaru
yeah because
this is really a massive position it's
not those type of possessions which
magnus still likes to play in in a rapid
time control
of course if if he is given this
position in a classical game then okay
no problems but i mean he's styling
rapid had been really so effective and
so powerful when he has those positions
which he perfectly understands where
there is so much harmony and then he
builds up the pressure and outplays
basically anyone on the planet
so this is a very tricky messy
position with lots lots at stake at each
and single move
and we have seen that hikaru had been
quite familiar with such positions
yesterday
absolutely well we saw yesterday a dream
start
and what we also saw you know overall as
a strategy that we felt that hikaru
found and played particularly well
is his opening preparation was really
great
he was putting a lot of challenges in
front of magnus almost from the get-go
causing the world champion to spend a
little bit more time than maybe he would
like to
which effected his play towards the end
of the game in critical positions in
game two yesterday the game that magnus
lost
he was in an in an endgame position
where he had two pawns for the exchange
under any kind of normal circumstances i
don't see magnus losing that ending but
he had so little time um
well it impacted his play let's just put
it that way so a great opening prep
by hikaru he's staying ahead on the
clock and this is this is maybe so hard
uh but so important
his errors his mistakes
were really minute he didn't make any
what i would call egregious blunder he
didn't
blunder badly i want to put it like that
and
that's
that's really really impressive and that
was why magnu pardon me that was why
hicaro won uh the first set um obviously
hikaro wants to do the very very same
thing after the move queen d5
peter
if i've got this right
magnus had
i don't know i'm just going to say 17
minutes
10 minutes ago because now he's burned
10 minutes
yeah almost i mean we missed out on on
queen d2 because i think the move queen
d2 was not entirely blitzed out but was
played after like 10 or 20 seconds
so yeah magnus really must have had
something like 17 minutes or 16
and burning so much time at just one one
single move on the other hand the
position justifies it
because it's so difficult to
to understand what your
first move should be and
if you lose control of your position
right here right now then even if you
have 50 minutes on the clock might
actually not help you so finding the
right move here is
is really very important on the other
hand finding it relatively quickly now
it's it's essential because if magnus
goes down to five minutes on the clock
for all this uh craziness then this will
this will hurt him big time later
and tanya you're with us what uh what
insights do you have for us tanya
yes just jumping in really quickly
because indeed magnus is taking a while
on this move and i think the point is
uh again i was checking with the
computer really quickly and briefly
after queen d5 actually the position uh
becomes a little more trickier instead
of queen d2 what magnus had to do was to
play rook g3 first and the point is now
queen d5 is just makes no sense at all
because you've got the g7 as well as
bishop f3 threats so actually queen d2
was a slight inaccuracy by the world
champion and uh i think that's the
reason why hikaru who is so extremely
well prepared took a few moments and
found out why
queen d2 does not work for white and now
magnus in a big thing down to five
minutes makes us a question again is uh
is he is he feeling it is because i
don't think we've seen him take so much
time on one move
thank you tanya absolutely i couldn't
agree more uh
a 10-minute thing is by far the longest
thing and
again for everybody who may be joining
us late the players start with 15
minutes so burning 10 of them on a
single move that means 66 percent of
your clock time and he's still
thinking so this is a this is the one if
i i think this is the longest thing
in the whole tournament and it must be
because the position
is so sharp
peter is about to say uh give us a get
your best guess of as to what he could
be thinking about and the moment uh
i was about to say that he finally did
play rook g3 peter
yeah magnus did play rgc simple i think
by elimination that this move had to be
played humanly speaking at least it
looked like the most natural move
however by burning so much time it was a
clear sign that magnus must have felt
that probably i mixed up something maybe
i hurried too much and i know this from
my own experience that when you are
following some computer preparation and
some small nuances change but you
remember that aha the whole point was
queen d2
but you remember i mentioned that this
97 was such a nice flexible
move humanly because it opens the d5
square
and uh hikaru made perfect use of it
after look g3
queen takes c5 had been played by hikaru
another big question is javier magnus
follow it up now he doesn't have much
time to think so i'm expecting his uh
answer rather quickly
exactly uh i
offered
queen f4
as a move um
do you have an alternative perhaps for
magnus because in truth he spent so much
time on the move rook g3 and cleantech
c5 was rather compulsory
you kind of think that magnus might have
had his next two or three moves uh ready
to go uh he hasn't played queen for a la
tempo
uh what did he do instead b4
yeah he played b4 and now c
b3
it's it's a really wow effect the big
question is objectively how good it is
well first i'm saying wow
then i'm saying why
uh
[Music]
why uh peter a queen takes a3 queen
takes a five
right
yes and
okay i get the fact that c7 is hanging
as well as g7
and this pawn on b3 is
you know wickedly uh up the board uh i
don't know uh
let's just say bishop d5 random move uh
well not so random but i i did want to
uh
sidestep queen take c7 and i did like i
did want to keep the beep on uh
i don't see rook takes g7 as as killing
me um
tanya
jump right in uh chaos on the board
tanyan
absolutely chaos on the board and i had
to jump right in because take a look at
one of the lines that i just saw uh
after you're totally right that this
position is what needs to be played
bishop a3 a very creative idea by the
world champion queen a3 queen a5 bishop
d5 needs to be played to defend this b3
pawn and now look at this rook takes b3
giving that
giving
up and the point is that after bishop b3
you jump in with knight b5 queen c5 is
not possible because you take knight c7
pick up the queen the best move on the
board for black is to go queen a4
instead
and now knight c7 check
king d7 queen b6 and we have a hot mess
on the board
oh my gosh alien chest this is my brain
hurts peter
yeah and if magnus had four cindys then
we understand why he spent all those 10
minutes
and bishop d5 on the board
yeah whoa
whoa whoa whoa this is
uh this is quite the way to start today
this was the kind of match
i think we were hoping for before the
finals began we saw magnus as having
such a dominant tour victories were a
little bit fearful this was going to be
a coronation dingler in robbed as of
that thought right away by winning the
first set in this match
uh
again this finals is just this is great
peter this is what we really really
wanted to see
i think we are very happy to see this
i'm not sure if magnus fans are so happy
about this because right i mean i
believe they really hope that magnus can
outclass hikaru but i mean in this type
of position this is crazy mess this is
the wild jungle which hikaru really
loves and needs to to show his best
and
okay kudos for
for magnus for being ready to to go for
all these shoppings on the other hand i
think it's not entirely voluntary it's
like
hikaru is also
inviting provoking him to to this jungle
so it's a very interesting uh
fight between the two players i love
that quote by michael tall
michael tall said that he'd like to
invite his opponent
into a jungle and that there was a very
narrow path just room enough for one
person
himself of course
and this right i mean rook takes b3 okay
if that lands on the board
i think we're going to get out our magic
wands and just do a a
a cavity check that's
that i mean the whole purpose of bishop
d5 right peter was to defend the pawn on
b3 and to see it smacked off the board
with that 95 variation that tanya was
mentioning that's just
i mean
what what can i say i mean
uh like i said my brain hurts we didn't
see that variation instead we've seen
rook
takes g7 peter
yeah i think it's a sign that magnus is
human after all yeah this move duct tape
g7 is yeah you understand that it's slow
but on the other hand okay you are
taking the g7 pawn you are also making
sure that black will never castle short
on the other hand the big problem is
that this pawn on bc is so powerful and
uh i'm not sure that white has enough
dynamic justification for for all these
but in a practical game i don't know how
to evaluate this i feel like the clocks
might play a really big role again i
mean look at this magnus is done to less
than three minutes while hikaru had like
nine minutes after g7 had been played a
very nice comfortable edge on the clock
and maybe just exactly what you need in
such a sharp position to to feel
comfortable
peter i don't know if you went down that
rabbit hole but i certainly fell
down that rabbit hole for a number of
weeks and i'm talking about the bodvinic
pawn sacrifice
and i spent some weeks trying to
understand it and again at the end of
the the period
my head was exploding i didn't know what
was going on and i wanted to suggest the
move c7 c5
as a move that would come right out of
that specific opening
because in the bodbinic pawn triangle
white has
been a pawn sacrifice pardon me white
has a big majority on the uh king side
and center and white and black on the
queen side
and you know the dynamics it's terrible
but this move c7 c5 i see is a key move
why well i've got two connected past
pawns i really want to have the
free
tempo knight e7 f5 i'm booting back
tonight and who knows maybe on a good
day i get to play b2 and make a
make a queen so i saw c5 as being
the best
move or crazy move and i just didn't
know where we were going after that we
do have a move on the board it's bishop
h5 theater
yeah bishop h5 played i have the feeling
it's played out of desperation because
black's position is so healthy and this
powerful knight on d5 the knight on e7
also the queen on ac is doing perfect
job because
it actually
uh defends the e7 knight once he
captures on d4 i rightly we have to
calculate crazy lines but
at first sight i still don't
entirely get what
magnus is really hoping for exactly so
if you don't mind we look at the most
obvious thing capture
give me the piece and what you were
saying there about queen a3 i really
couldn't agree with you more you take on
d4 let's say you take with the rook on
f7 just to show as an example and we
move the king let's say to d7 now the
queen on a3
is so
brilliantly placed because you don't
have any rook takes e7 check and queen
c7 ideas peter
yeah absolutely i mean this is uh this
is completely crazy
i mean
i don't know what to think of this
position
this is
just in other words
f7 king d7 and bishop g4 played uh this
is the idea now this incredible
queen takes d5 idea is there
okay
[Music]
wow
that that that that is a very unique
double pin uh the knight can
after queen takes d5 the knight's in an
absolute pin but also the pawn on e6
is an absolute pin that's a very unusual
uh
you know kind of a crossfire theater
yeah i mean okay this is
this is just wild i mean bishop g4 but
i don't know this is
i i'm not believing in it i mean where
is this
call me skeptical as well peter i i
yeah uh you're not attacking with a lot
i mean i i might be so bold as to point
out that king e8 bishop h5 king d7
uh
you know is kind of like it's black
who has a choice uh uh of playing for a
win or not but you're about to suggest
king c6 and i like that move because
again the queen on a3 does this great
job
of defending the knight but also the
square uh c1 as you're pointing out
yeah it's such a multi-purpose queen on
ac and this king c6 is a typical
botvinic move i mean you already talked
about this similarities between this
position and the botunic variation
and okay i just imagine jan smith the
dutch player who used to be one of the
guys playing the
playing the botvinic variation the
highest level in all these vikanze
tournaments and i'm pretty sure that he
would love to play the move king c6 also
luke family is someone who would just
love to
march forward with his king and i'm even
not not seeing the refutation because
something like rook takes e7 queen takes
c7 rook c1 check will be answered by
king b7 and again we see this brilliant
harmony of blacks bishop on d5 and queen
e7 covering all the squares possible on
the board i
i i don't see what's wrong with queen's
king c6 but maybe there is even
something else
uh king c6 looks like a really good move
you and you mentioned uh jans mates well
john's mates irwin
la me and daniel stellwager were ims and
they came over
they called them my louts they came over
and we studied chess and uh daniel
stellweg and in particular he wanted to
study
the bod venice pond sacrifice
and
it it's a terrible terrible variation i
mean there's no strategic understanding
there's no motifs
everything everything about that
variation this calculation calculation
calculation
and i mean i kicked him out of the
apartment and discussed it was pretty
funny bishop takes e6 peter
what is that oh
no i still don't understand it what is
going on here
yeah i don't know i mean the bishop
takes c6 basically probably had to be
played bishop takes e6 look f6 on the
board now okay
magnus magnus has to try to fish
somewhere i mean
but but i just cannot believe that this
this could ever work yeah i mean it's
it's two pieces and you don't have this
feeling that this is causing such damage
for black okay after king d7 yeah king
d7 on the board queen b6 blitzed out
yeah
white hitting the bishop on e6 planning
to go queen b7 check exactly
but okay there are so many questions
first of all one thing after uh
[Music]
bishop d5 just i i don't know how scary
is a check on d6 i'm just running away
exactly yeah bishop d5 and it's on the
board
yeah how i mean two pieces peter
yeah two pieces and two very nice pieces
guarding the king and
for example yeah oh sorry yes okay yeah
look this explained
i mean kingi it looks very natural and
it almost feels like white has to
sacrifice his look as well but
this this will never end in a perpetual
exactly so something like rook takes d5
knight takes d5 queen c6 jack you are
picking up some material but just what
you're saying peter you've sacrificed so
much
king e7 that looks like a really good
move to me again that queen on a3 so
brilliantly placed
no queen d5 checks for you
yeah i don't know because if i take on
d5 it looks way too slow so it feels
almost obligatory to try to check king
e6 try one more check
and uh
if you take on e5 then suddenly my loop
joins the the party that's that's some
hope or first even f for check i mean at
least there is something but i'm not not
even believing that black is forced to
play like this exactly
exactly yeah king e8 played magnus down
to two minutes hikaru has a little bit
over three
right
by the way another thing i mean we we
we're really harping on the
uh play of the players uh time
management
especially in these long matches
uh is
is rather
an important skill set to have
especially
uh when you get into the armageddons as
well as the
uh
blitz games
um i'm thinking that uh hikaru's time
management has been
very impressive
yeah absolutely i mean
somehow he combines and we are seeing
exactly that that variation that we have
been
uh discussing on the board and probably
not the move king f5
would be the more professional move i
mean but
again hikaru has the time and he can
decide
he can calculate everything very
carefully that can he take on e5 or
should he
go king
f5 i'm looking at a variation peter king
f5
i know it looks a little bit crazy g
no g4 check king takes g4
queen g6 check yeah i'm dreaming of
involving my rook but
i
i'm coming uh
empty-handed
wow
quite a quite a journey by black's king
huh
yeah and it's a little bit scary to put
the king on h5i
i just wanted to illustrate that there
is such option as well because i'm not
seeing mate and finally if black gets
the move look ag 18 then the black king
might walk back to the corner
after all the queen is is alone
and this knight on d5 covers so many
check options so white will have to
eventually capture this knight but if
you capture the knight then you are
losing very important time
so this is not
really an option another question if
after king f5
instead of g4 check which is of course
the most natural one do you have the
time to to capture this knight or not
absolutely let's take a look at that
queen takes
uh d5 now we're a whole rook ahead but
the issue is with our king so
we we want to go king g6 to h7 but we
want to make sure
that we we
we can keep the squares covered
specifically the f7 square so i like
that move peter what you've just showed
queen f7
also a little
we have seen some move repetition but
i'm i'm not buying it i cannot really
believe vehicle going for the repeat
with king e7 because if k7 queen b7
check will bumble on the board it will
be three for the three times the
petition
okay
so this is the moment
the moment of truth is he playing for a
win or is he willing to accept a draw to
start the opening set of day two
of this
magnus carlsen to our finals benefiting
kiva uh again king f5 uh peter it looks
it's on the board oh it is on the board
and queen takes d5 queen e7 so exactly
as as we discussed the e6 check
the most natural move is queen e7 but
there was some argument to be made for
rook f8 as well so that your king could
waltz its way back now uh
peter
a rook is a rook it's got a lot of pawns
but what's happening after queenie for
chat
yeah well i hope to run away but
the king g7 okay
and queen takes d4 jack yeah yeah i'm
gonna go i believe queen f6
okay i'm gonna try to keep you as disc
coordinated as possible
so
queen check on g4 yeah
on g4
okay then i go king h7 and i know king
h7 you go if queen e4 check yeah
precisely and queen g6 check queen b7
and this would be a draw exactly that
was my hope
yeah so this is what black has to watch
out
not to let happen and yeah hikaru did
very nice he moved the king to g8
and this is after queen g4 check he had
the move queen g7 okay
so now he is securing
um his king
and uh lookie lookie the pawn on b3 is
still on the board uh
peter
and not only on the board it's pushed to
was about to say uh as long as that pawn
is alive i mean it's worth the rook on
h8 that rook on h8 one day we'll get
into the game there's no question it
will you play rook h7 and king h8 and
tuck that but if that pawn on b2 stays
then there's nothing to discuss it's
simply game over
yeah magnus played the move f4
and that was like
rook v8 played by hikarwa temple
basically signaling that yes i know that
you are just uh
bluffing me exactly
because i'm confident enough
yeah and that move rook b8 it's a really
really nice move as you're threatening
and to
uh the move f4 was designed of course
give me the right give me the chance to
play f5 and f6 and
maybe i can cause some chaos uh the move
rook
b8
uh just takes all the sales out of
white's position i think
that's
game over again i look at the players
and every time i look at magnus i have
this impression that i really don't
i just don't okay now there i kind of
feel like he's
like disappointed and he caro is bobbing
his head he's bobbing and weaving he's
feeling it and what a start to this set
the second set uh peter
yeah and queen e4 being answered with
luke h7 also almost instantly the black
king is finding a very very nice shelter
on h8 with the queen on g7
yeah magnus played the move rugby one
but uh i think already magnus is getting
ready for the for the next game because
because he knows that that's it this is
lost
exactly so i would play something like a
queen a7
check i would just like to make sure
that whenever you play king h1 i've got
a back rank checkmate just to make you
know that absolutely sure but uh hikaru
felt that queen queen b7 was the right
uh
move and i'm not going to dispute that
looks really good too peter yeah and
magnus already designed after queen b7
queenie to look c7 just sealed it i mean
black is letting group c1 there are no
more checks just one last check on g4
but already black king can escape to h8
so yeah it's a shocking defeat for for
magnus because he came up with a
prepared clipper line and uh maybe
just surprised by one of the move orders
he forgot the preparation or he just
remembered this move queen d2 yeah
because this queen d2 was the the cause
of trouble
and after quindi to suddenly black had
this very important intermediate move
intel mezzo with queen d5 and
practically speaking it was clear that
black is taking over and we have tanja
with us yeah
tanya
that was absolutely explosive so
hikaru nakamura is on a one side lead
and going into set two he has uh won the
first game which means that magnus
carlsen is playing catch-up on set two
as well
i have no idea what's going on here i
mean this has been
absolutely
i want to say unexpected but the way
hikaru is playing it's making us believe
like this is going to be the tone of the
match i mean it's just been incredible
chess by hikaru and peter let's go
through this game really quickly because
i got a shot i got a chance to look at
it and you are completely right that
here after queen d2 allowing queen d5
was perhaps uh uh the moment when things
sort of got out of hand for the world
champion the difference of course
between this game and what we saw in the
same line yesterday in game two was when
magnus went for a4 in the opening
instead of a3 and i just think like that
showed that he's coming in with the
preparation he's ready to take on hikaru
in an opening that's extremely dynamic
you know when you know your opponent has
won a game in a particular opening it's
a really good idea if you can find some
new some new ways to play but hikaru was
prepared to take on a4 and in this
particular position before queen d2
he had to go rook g3 just making sure
that it's harder for black to go queen
d5 and pick up the c5 pawn so easily
instead he went queen d2 it's still fine
it might not be the best move but it's
still fine and after queen d5 let's play
on peter he went rook g3 the one thing
that surprised me was also here he took
he took about 10 minutes on the clock to
make this move which you would think you
know 30 seconds 40 seconds you're
getting mated on g2 you don't want to
you you don't want to play a move like
bishop f3 because of queen c5 rook g3
you play much faster 10 minutes almost
10 minutes burnt on the clock for this
move let's go on here hikaru took the
pawn on c5 and yes you were on your
money with the suggestion that white has
to go queen f4 because black's got this
threat of evil either going long castle
or rook d8 and pinning the knight along
the d-file queen f4 keeps things complex
on the board not an easy position at all
gets messy but this would have been the
direction he needs to he needed to take
instead magnus went for b4 and my hunch
is that b4 is the entire idea that he
was calculating before going rook g3
which is why he took a while because he
blitzed out g4 not a b4 not a move that
you play so quickly and here this very
creative bishop a3 again not objectively
the best move because computer just
suggests to take the pawn on b3 but
here to just go knight b3 but what he
probably didn't like was that now white
is forced black white is forced to trade
off after queen d5 exactly so instead he
goes for this bishop a3 line and i just
quickly want to show you the point where
everything went berserk after bishop a3
he took on a3 this is all fine takes on
a5 the position is still extremely
complex he had the idea to go rook b3
and like we were discussing this
position it would have been very messy
just to quickly go through this line
knight b5
queen a4 has to be played it's the only
move on the board and knight c7 king d7
queen b6 threatening the rook on a
threatening queen b6 check black has to
go queen c6
and this position this um is actually
fine for black and black is able to keep
things under control so let's just back
up a little bit but this was the best
line for white to play after this
creative b4 bishop a3 stuff that he did
go for after rook g7 the
it's
the computer just calls out
the bad position that white has and
again you both were completely right it
is because of the c and b pawn which is
going to make life very difficult for
the world champion and hikaru just found
the best moves on the board to counter
any threats any ideas along the board
the only interesting uh
interesting moment in this game was
let's play on after after c5
[Music]
let's have that on the
board bishop h5 was interesting of
course he could the the world champion
could have just retreated with the
knight as well but then you're just
giving an advantage king f8 rook g8
everything gets neutralized if you make
a move like knight f3 on the board
perhaps knight f5 k it's just black's
doing great the c5 the b3 pawn are just
too strong instead
bishop h5 on the board after c5 and
things got really messy but actually
black white never has enough
compensation for this piece and if you
just move on a little bit to the point
where after king d7 bishop g4 and here
what i really liked was that hikaru made
his intentions really clear after king
c16 saying that you know what i'm not
repeating with king eight i know i'm
better i know i can defend this position
it looks like a mess but i thrive on on
a messy position and that's exactly what
he did after king c6 bishop e6
and the point where he went rook f6
it's
it looks really dangerous for black but
actually this queen on a3 defends
everything and after king d7 we had this
move queen b6
rook to d6 was played and this is a
point that i think was um
was a little interesting king e8
there is something that white has a
chance in which i will show you shortly
but actually king c8 is a really good
move and it looks like you're walking in
in a danger zone and a very difficult
move to make on the board of course
because uh you know you're playing in a
rapid format one check and it's game
over but the thing is that the knight on
e7 and the bishop on d5 defend
everything and after rook t5 knight d5
queen c6 doesn't work because of knight
c7
and queen e6 you just go king b8 and
everything is under control but king
eight is definitely the human move
[Music]
and let's back up
here king he ate a bishop d5 rook t6 and
this position after knight d5
it's a complete mess on the board and i
don't know you perhaps peter and yes you
could explain this better to us but
after queen c6 king
e7 the line that we were looking at
again queen b seven happened kingy six
happened this this was all played on the
board magnus down on the clock majorly
still trying to keep the game alive and
now queen c6 king
f5
and queen d5 queen e7
here white could have just
the computer actually says that white
after taking on b3
black is clearly better but it's you
know there is still there are still
chances not really chances but you know
he still has to find some defense of the
king and i was expecting a much bigger
advantage on the computer but it gives
around plus 1.5 with the brief look that
i had
wow
which was very very strange but of
course the king finds its safety and i
think when you're playing on minutes and
you're down a rook it's almost
impossible to find anything with black
in this position uh the idea is to go f4
next
but it's just i think it's hard to
believe that anyone can survive this
position with the black pieces despite
despite being a king in the center and a
couple of pawns down but i was surprised
with the engine evaluation
what a start by hikaru nakamura
let's just have the last position on the
board
yes like like you said this b2 pawn just
there's just nothing to fight for here
and what a win by hikaru we had
and we are gonna have
kickoff really soon so magnus carlsen
playing catch up in their set to match
again hikaru nakamura showing exactly
the approach that he did
in
uh in yesterday's set and it's going to
be interesting to watch if we if magnus
i i'm predicting
hikaru to go e4 and
i'm not and i'm wondering if
magnus is going to reply with the naidoc
because
that would again mean going into complex
position and perhaps could mean hikaru
better prepared
he's finding it easier to take on such
positions and before we do have liftoff
and we bring in some of the insights
that we've received from our viewers of
course we've got a heart drop from the
world champion with his course on
trustable on the on end gameplay it's
called the magnus touch endgame
definitely check that out and also take
a look at
the the the 20 minute free license which
gives you an idea of what the course is
about take a look at this
you still seem kind of upset about that
inaccuracies
later yeah which is why
whenever this game is brought up i'm
like
[Music]
now indeed and a very very educational
and an instructive and a mega
entertaining course just we saw in that
last position the ideas of how to place
your pieces how to go f5 and create
those counter those past pawns in end
games
learn how to play endings like a pro
definitely check that course out let's
take a look at what we had on twitter as
well
we had christopher writing in with
hikaru is to continue winning the match
due to his greatest team and magnus has
to get out of his doubts and step up if
he is to catch up yes and peter
when i was watching these two on the cam
uh and also seeing that pace
i also got the feeling like magnus is
doubting himself a little bit on the
moves he's taking just that
that extra time not 10 minutes burning
10 minutes for a move like rook g3 in a
classical game still makes a lot of
sense but in this rapid format
it does feel like he's struggling a bit
with his rhythm did you feel that as
well
absolutely tanya uh struggling is a very
good way of describing what i saw i
don't i can't recall a professional
grandmaster using two-thirds of this
dime on one
move
and that really was a a big surprise but
as you went through the game tanya i
mean
you know we're in the fire right so like
uh our uh we're nervous about the moves
but when you went through the whole game
and you presented it holistically if you
will
uh i became more and more aware that
well
hikaru just played a very good game
i mean please do point out where he
errored
otherwise i mean he was just he just
kept playing a lot of good good moves
and he was very practical about his own
handling of the clock so overall peter
uh jump right in i i'm thinking that
that uh
carl was a deserved winner of that game
absolutely yesterday i mean
clearly he deserved to win i think the
only problem for magnus was that i mean
having lost the set yesterday and coming
eager to bounce back it must have been
an incredible psychological blow when he
realized that he he mixed up the moves
and because of mixed up maybe instead of
having a nice preparation on the board
he's maybe practically lost and when you
realize that that suddenly with divide
pieces you are presenting your opponent
basically a free victory because the
point is the way how good hikaru is
playing it's
magnus must feel that whenever he loses
control he will be punished and
you know before getting punished you
might feel that you have a way to to get
out of it but yesterday he got punished
so by now he will must feel like he has
to have everything under control and all
of a sudden just with 70 minutes on the
clock he bleeds one more move out way
too fast and things turned and hikaru
jumped with queen d5 at the chance and
played a brilliant game and magnus never
had a chance in this game to come back
wow
tanya back to you
absolutely peter and uh definitely a
very very difficult start and a
nightmare of a start with the white
pieces like you pointed out and clearly
it was a prep that magnus had come with
playing ea4 playing this line that we
saw yesterday and it just does not work
what is it that the world champion is
going to bring in game two he's
definitely got to
step it up
uh we'll find out as you can see we've
got a countdown going on we've got about
another minute so perhaps we could get
another tweet up before we go to the
action because we heard some we got some
really interesting stuff and of course
hikaru setting the day with day two
office and let's play this um
uh
yes there he is
and again so far this tweet has aged
rather well because winning that game
won with the black pieces in
set two could not it could not have
started better and like you you pointed
out that really
he deserved it he he just he may he
played fast he made he played accurately
he played dynamically he was not scared
of the position the mess on the board
took all the action head on uh we're up
we're about to lift off so peter yes uh
what are our opening predictions do you
think we'll see a night off
i definitely am with you a hundred
percent on the one e2 e4 prediction
hikaru has been dictating quite well
with the white pieces with one e4
conversely
magnus has not gotten good games with
either the night or f or well his
sicilian
so i wouldn't be surprised if we see e4
of berlin
and oracaru khan i just don't think that
the sicilian is bringing it for the
world champion peter your thoughts
well my thought is that after the game
what just had happened i feel like
magnus wants to play a quiet game just
to to get into the game and play a
normal chess and get back to his
strengths and e4 on the board and e5 on
the board yeah i'm i'm liking this
because now what magnus silly needs to
do is to calm down because he had lost
the first set he jumped at hikaru and he
lost uh with the white pieces the very
first game if he still wants to to turn
this set
then he needs a drona he needs to to
settle down then
or
it's also i mean just to play solid
because
it's also not clear for hikar what he
should be doing
uh because
okay after all there are two more games
but we are seeing one of the lines which
hikaru had used against magnus in their
match in lindor
when
hikaru knocked magnus out
and this is a very very solid line from
from hikaru i don't know if he has
drewish intentions and says that okay
please magnus you will get one more wide
game and in that game you have to to
burn all bridges
uh
i i don't know but right now having this
position on the board this very large
position it might be a signal yeah and
we are seeing repetition maybe
wow well again i
i think that's a very practical decision
by uh ikaru to say okay i mean i won
with black
this is like the greatest thing in the
world ever
and we've seen quite a number of grand
master draws in this very very precise
um
well grandmaster draw uh
and he karu is basically saying you
gotta beat me i'm not gonna do what i
did with daniel duboff and beat myself
i'll make a draw with white and you've
got to come back and win game three
otherwise i don't see you winning on
demand with uh with the black pieces
well a little cynical peter but hey look
this is a match right you you just
you're there to win the match not
necessarily to win the hearts and minds
of the public
yeah well i mean this has different
aspects because if now magnus field
bounds back and hikaru loses today's set
then everybody will heavily criticize
hikaru that of course how could you have
done this it was not the right way to do
it but if he just smoothly goes on and
wins the match today i mean the second
set then everybody will say wow it was
what a great
uh
decision because i mean giving away the
white pieces just like this it's it's
never easy
there is also however another
aspect you know and it might mean that
hikaru knows that
magnus was not feeling comfortable in
the first game against this variation in
the vienna which he prepared and by
immediately forcing good law in this
game he gives no time for team magnus to
really come up with a new idea there and
if magnus has to switch from that
opening then maybe hikaru will feel like
aha i achieved something i forced my
opponent somewhere where he actually had
no intention of going before the match
so there are all kinds of aspects and
that's why i'm loving this format
because if it would be in a tournament
then the public would go crazy like wow
what is this disrespecting the public
this is draw and like this but for the
whole show for the whole entertainment
and for the whole match
this game actually is not important
because the match is thrilling and we
will be still seeing incredible fights
before this second set ends
absolutely and uh i as i was watching
you on the broadcast peter i saw the
green bar the green bar is our kiva bar
we are raising money for kiva and
helping
their cause and our goal
for this finals was to raise fifty
thousand dollars from the chess
community and i'm seeing as much green
or well maybe a little just a smidge
more white but thank you each and every
one of you for contributing to our
impact chess campaign
and helping uh the global community with
micro lending please go to akeeba.com
and check out their organization and all
the things that they do yesterday we had
henrikhi he was on our show and he
talked all about
akiva and i hope you got a chance to
catch that segment because it really
sounds like a great and worthwhile
effort to support so thank you for that
and you can also support kiva by
um becoming a a premier member uh chest
24 check it out there's a coupon code
kiva finals that you can use which gives
you a 30 discount to begin with and 50
of your money is going to go to the kiba
campaign as well so a great time tanya
to become a premier member and to
support
our
uh keeper
uh campaign
agree yes i think it's just a great time
to get into chess i think there's just
so much going on
um it's it's just an amazing game that
survived the pandemic and given us so
much joy with this entire magnus carlson
chess store the broadcasts that we've
had the games we've had the action we've
had with the very best and the very the
most the
strongest players in the world coming to
fight for high high price funds as well
as showing absolute world class play in
a rapid and blitz format it's been an
incredible journey and a big shout out
to the world champion and the chess 24
team for setting up
uh this magnus carlson chess store so
that all of us can sit back and enjoy
with some popcorn and of course you're
totally right an amazing deal with the
30 off on premium membership you also
get access to video series by our
authors there's the world champion
vishyanan there's world champion magnus
carlsen grandmaster jan gustafsson
grandmaster peter swiddler and many
others who've done intense training
courses
on openings and middle games and end
games that you have to check out and
like you said yes it's a great way to
invest in your own education but also
impact the society and impact the
community because you are supporting
kiba 50 of all premium memberships go to
kiba's campaign to help underserved
community communities survive this
challenge the good news of course
doesn't stop there because we also have
the magnus carlson chess course on end
games from chesapeal which has been
released you have to check it out
there's an inaugural 40 off on it so a
great time to to learn all about the
endings and how to play that i think the
last game that we had between magnus and
hikaru the quick draw that we saw in
this um
uh in this opening
as
as uh alexander gristchuck says you know
it's the soviet approach the
professional approach when something
goes wrong and you're shaky and you've
lost the game
the good thing the professional thing
the right thing to do after that is to
stabilize is to just uh you know maybe
just play a little solid a quick draw
get your get your nerves back together
just get yourself get yourself together
and then have a go at it again and
magnus carlsen will be playing game
three with the white pieces as peter you
pointed out an extremely important game
because this is
this is the final uh white that the
world champion
will have
in today's set we're gonna be back with
the action soon check out this trailer
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Music]
[Applause]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help under-served
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
you look at farmers in the rural areas
of tanzania and uganda the way that they
farm is very manual labor intensive and
they can't afford to buy equipment
outright and so we're focused on raising
the level of income by selling
productive use equipment with financing
[Music]
foreign
a
[Music]
what
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah i know years later
yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up online
indeed a very educational
and instructive course on endings i
think that's one part of the game that
we all really struggle in and if the
world champion gives some help in that
and gives us tips and tricks on how to
improve i think you've got to grab it
but some big news uh yas and peter i
and a big shout out to actually our
audience who pointed it out to me on
twitter
that game one there was actually a big
save for magnus carlsen
right in this position he played e6 and
e6 is a terrible blunder and the game is
out of hand but instead of e6 he had
this stunning line but i have to say
that it's very difficult to play this on
the board and it's a computer line the
move is rook c1
just a quiet move
but an
very impressive move and i think the
only way that i can break this down is
that you have to bring the rook into the
game to have some chances of giving
checks on the board of creating any
trouble for black skin let's see how
this line progresses of course there are
multiple ways in which black can react
the best move here is b2 queen e5 in
fact is a big blunder and white is check
mating after queen f7 and regardless of
where black's king goes it doesn't
matter there is a mate follow-up uh
because now the rook is in the game so
instead of queen e5 b2 is the line and
here queen f3 white has to be extremely
precise
queen f3 king g6
rook c6 check
king goes to g7
and queen g4 check
again this is all pretty fast black has
no better move than king f8 here white
goes queen f5 has to go king eight
because g8 runs into mate or a queen
loss king e8 is the only move queen g6
track and take a look at this guys after
king d7 rook d6 king c8 rook c6 king d7
rip d6 was actually a draw in this
position i think the most difficult
point in this entire line is to find the
move rooksy one and i have a feeling
that if uh magnus would have found rook
c1 the follow-up itself is not that hard
we do have liftoff so let's get straight
to the action
uh and we'll come back to what's going
on on the social media connect with us
using the hashtag impactchest
thank you tanya thank you to our
audience what a remarkable move um
peter rooksy won i would describe that
as alien chance it never entered my
consciousness
what a move
what a save that might have been
yeah absolutely i mean those are the
moves that you can find in
correspondence chess but not with not
with one minute on the clock and also
you know the point was that the way they
reached this position did not give
magnus the feeling that he has a
perpetual check yeah i mean it felt like
it's desperate attempt to continue and
he kind of acknowledged that yeah if
black plays correct like hikaru did then
probably he's losing so this is one of
the most difficult things to
to shift in in the mindset of a chess
player that when you don't have the
logic behind what is happening then you
can miss out that such computer moves
exactly now
let me just set the table for everybody
who can join us late again shame on you
for joining us late because we are in
the magnus carlson tour finals we are in
day two
uh it's a seven set affair the first
player to win four days of competition
hikaru won the first day of competition
he leads he leads one set to love uh
magnus fans was hoping that magnus would
snap back and tie
the set but guess what on our opening
game
magnus with the white pieces went down
in an absolute chaotic thriller game two
was a perfunctory grand master draw as
carl made a very very short draw with
the white pieces and now i think this is
literally all or nothing magnus is i
think
really mathematically speaking in a
must-win situation right here he has to
win this game with white to tie this sat
peter
yeah that's that's for sure i mean with
white it's the last white game
i mean you know that you have to try to
use all your chances and
it's very interesting how magnus
approaches this game and let's just go
back right to the start because
a lot of finesses i mean we have also
seen yesterday magnus using one c4 in a
must-win situation on in game four in
their first set hikaru
answered it with e5 and the first little
move that's kind of a
i wouldn't call it a surprise but
something new compared to the first set
is the move g3 so magnus deviates and he
kind of anticipates that hikaru always
relies on this uh knight f6 bishop g2 d5
setup and if he is ready to play this
setup then this move order with g's the
bishop g2
we without placing the knight to cc
makes perfect sense because it gives
white more options and after knight c6
castles knight b6 magnus
indicates that yeah i want to make use
of this if i ever get my bishop to b2
with the knight on b1 yet then i'm
putting immediate pressure however
hikaru played the
move bishop e6 basically trying to make
sense that aha i understand that you
want me to get somewhere let me not uh
go along your way so he went bishop e6
and now magnus changed the strategy and
played them with queen c2 and queen d7
had been played by luke d1 to be honest
i have never seen this position in my
life
and i played the english most of my life
and i've never seen the position peter
so
that makes two of us
and uh castles whoa
okay we kind of set the table and said
yeah
hikaru wants to play
chaotic
games full
blooded full-bodied games that feature
just a lot of intense play where you
know there's a great deal of pressure on
both sides at each and every turn this
move
castles i would say that ups the ante
peter do you know what the word anti
means when you play poker
no no it basically means i'm putting
more money into the pot i'm i'm raising
the pressure i'm raising the ante
with this moves castles long as both
kings are on opposite flanks
yeah but uh
i have the feeling that uh
after
black committed bishop e6 and queen d7
the long castle was kind of the logical
follow-up because white is ready to for
example let's just imagine that black
mix is the plants and goes bishop e7
white has the option of going bishop b2
hitting the e5 pawn and if you play f6
then all of a sudden white brings the
center with a very timely d2d4 and the
position opens up before black managed
to castle and suddenly
the long diagonal opens and black might
be in big big trouble so if already
having said avid bishop e6 and quincy to
queen d7 then long castle had to be
played now also the reason why magnus
switches the strategy and develops the
knight first to cc is that a move like
bishop b2 could be really unpleasantly
answered by bishop f5 hitting the queen
and there is no good way of dealing with
that because after dc black has the move
e5 e4 using the
d file
and e4 of course is not an option
because after bishop g4 you're doing
your structure and black is
strategically uh winning uh move like
quincy vanilla also all kinds of
activities so white had to develop the
knight in order to have sent the control
after bishop f5 he can make a move dc
and we see that the rook is protected
thanks to the knight on c3 so just to be
clear e5 e4 is no longer a threat
because after d takes e4 the knight on
c3 protects the rook and uh white is for
choice no question after the move knight
c3 peter we've seen
f7f6
that slows down any potential of knight
g5 and you know again when i ever see
these positions where the kings are on
opposite flanks i always think to myself
that these are the hardest
types of middle game positions to play
why
because the pressure is on both players
to start
attacking
plans against the opposing king
so this move f7 f6 the prelude to g5 h5
h4
and the fact that black's king is
already on the queen side uh white's
natural reaction is to try to play a3 b4
or maybe 94 knight c5 uh
how do you see the uh
the various plans before the players
yeah this reminds uh reminds me and
probably everyone who is familiar with
chess of the dragon structure with
reverse colors of course it's
it's different it has completely new
elements and dynamics i do believe that
if white starts to play on the queen
side it's going to be too slow because
actually black just needs to move g5 and
g4 kicking uh the knight away from fc
and then he will get a lovely control of
the default squad with his knight on on
c6
so to my mind actually it's a race of of
tempes
and white has to make sure that he he
breaks out he has this d to d4 move
ready before before black gets g5 g4 in
because after
this comes white will never have enough
time
right
okay so now having said that
uh since g5 g4 is
as you say uh threatening and white
really does want to get in this d4 i
like what you're doing peter i like this
move bishop b2 and i like
answering g5 with the move d4
uh
yeah i mean again talk about upping the
annie and making it as double edged
literally fire on the board everywhere
in the center and the king side on the
queen side this is great stuff peter
yeah absolutely i mean the only problem
again magnus is forced to burn time
because he knows that this position is
is very crucial
and
yeah i hope for him and i think uh a
part of all the hikaru fans everybody is
hoping that yeah magnus finds back to
himself and uh he comes back and we will
see a
thrilling second set because yesterday
was fantastic and magnus plays d4
immediately basically
even feeling that
maybe
there is no time to waste for bishop b2
he wanted to make sure that he gets d4
because ah even the point is that after
bishop b2 maybe black could simply play
knight d4 this is really powerful and
knight takes d4 e takes d4
and uh you never get d4 in and if black
will have a chance of destroying your
structure with dc then
you don't even want to see that in this
regard then d4 was like almost the only
move
but
then why did magnus take so much time
yeah there are all these aspects very
interesting
yeah okay so after d4 uh let's imagine
uh there's a pawn to be captured peter
let's take it
yeah and he gotta take it e takes d4
played
i'm somehow okay i'm not guessing
anything sorry because it's just way too
complicated i almost said that knight b5
would be natural but it runs into knight
before exactly knight b5 uh threatening
the pawn on d4 stopping bishop c5 so uh
black can not defend the pawn on d4 with
bishop c5 c5 but knight b5 unfortunately
as you spotted runs into knight before
there is the continuation queen e4 but i
think that the variation and stops
quite shortly
after bishop d5
yeah i mean it just feels wrong and
magnus is not interested in about this
whole process he says yes it was very
important for me to get d4 in let me
continue quietly developing bishop b2 as
if nothing happened because this pawn on
d4 is is not running away
a very very restrained move indeed wow
all i can say is i'm spotting a lot of
tactics in the position and i'm not sure
that tactically things are actually
going to work out for
our world champion here imagine king b8
peter
and again imagine king b8 94 just to put
a move on the board
there is a move like night before
to be followed by
[Music]
d4d3
yes white will win back his pawn
but maybe not in the nicest way peter
yeah whenever you have to take ed3 to to
take back the phone it's uh i think you
just stop right there you you don't want
to look further
i feel like move knight e4 is definitely
not
uh magnus has in mind okay on the other
hand also the move king b8 i think the
the position is so difficult to play and
there are so many different options this
is maybe one of the
real problems of of rapid chase that
when you are
confronted with such position uh how
much time can you afford to take to make
the right decision here yeah you
understand that probably are in control
and if you would be playing the kodak
move everything is fine while you are
risking that if you play too fast uh you
let the control slip out of your hands
but uh
but yeah the move king b8 of course very
natural however there are also moves
like bishop f5 come
coming to mind because it hits the queen
on seat when this queen on c2 is quite
harmonious uh it's another big question
how white is gonna deal with a move like
bishop f5 to my mind there are millions
of questions and i don't know the
answers yet
true uh the reason i picked king b8
because in rapid chess you often have to
sacrifice
the perfect for the good and what i mean
to say by that is in rapid chess you
just need to make a lot of good moves
just a lot of good moves consistently
and quickly in classical chats you're
definitely looking for the perfect move
for each and every situation as you have
time to burn in rapid chests you really
don't want to get behind on the clock
having said that i must say that it's
nice to see both players with a very
balanced 10 minutes apiece
peter your move was ikaru's choice
bishop f5 just putting the question to
the queen
yeah i think it's just way too tempting
i mean uh because you again feel like
how will white react and if you don't
know the answer you want to find find
out and you also have the feeling that
if you do not you don't know the answer
then maybe your opponent also doesn't
know the answer so please burn some time
there are all all the reasons in the
world why you should be thinking and
thinking and thinking
and thank you very much that's exactly
what i want from you
exactly so bishop f
five and again uh
i'm thinking queen c1 peter and just
okay again i don't want to burn ten
minutes as magnus
did in an earlier game of the set and
the throw throw the ball essentially
back to hikaru
now that you put my queen on c1 maybe
knight b5
is really a okay you've made the answer
and that answer was d4d3 as you said e
takes d3 is a move i really want to shy
away from
and
if i'm going to shy away from that i got
to kick the bishop so maybe
night oh knight h4d2 how embarrassing
oh my goodness
show that to our audience by oh
now that's a that's a queen trap you
don't see very often peter
how did the pawn get to d2
yeah not at all and uh the point behind
bishop f5 of course to play d for d3
uh but actually it was not my move it
was hikaru's move d3 oh i apologize i
didn't realize that we were actually
uh i thought the players were thinking
of it so d3 on the board so take away
take back that knight h4 move because
that's definitely not the move
that
magnus uh wants to play okay d3 peter uh
a challenge indeed
yeah very big challenge because
i mean you don't want to play e takes d3
you also don't want to tolerate this
pawn on d3
you don't want to go e4 because it
weakens your structure plus it closes
your bishop plus also the black pawn on
dc remains so maybe you want it or not
you have to
take edc and then try to push d4 and try
to use this phone as a
as a trojan horse i mean just at all
cost you you keep on pushing it and you
don't care if it's lost or not just just
push it exactly
huh
well i've again i'm
i'm terrible i i really i'm looking at
the players and uh
for me you know
the bobbing and weaving when i see that
i i usually think that uh it means that
icaru's satisfied i look at magnus and i
just can't read the man i just don't
know
you know how
what he makes out of the position okay
uh sorry peter there there was one trick
though if you go
e4
and bishop g4 the one trick
is if is there a possibility of say
knight d5
and i want to take with the rook on d3
after that capture
and i'm hoping that
uh
i'll regain material equality oh night
before okay rook d4 uh just to continue
the the variation for sac
yeah but it looks uh very little
somehow it doesn't doesn't look right it
doesn't feel right
i'm i'm just not exactly sure though
well i mean in certain way the trumps
that white has is that the rook on h8
and the bishop on f8 are still
fortunately for him
out of the game
and we did see e takes d3 definitely a
move that magnus was not pleased about
peter
yeah definitely not i mean
i can imagine that black objectively
should be better and also he's in a
situation that actually white is
supposed to win this game in order to to
come back in the match
exactly the the big question is however
for me that
i mean if hikaru feels that he has a
chance then i believe he should try to
take it because after all
why would you leave it to the last game
if you feel that there is a chance to to
be able to finish the match earlier
and uh and magnus had to take risk and
he has done
some things to his position positionally
which are very much uh
anti magnus yeah because he doesn't like
to damage his pawn structure all this
harmony is kind of gone we have seen
hikaru playing bishop h3 bishop h1 also
blitzed out
i mean uh clearly if magnus would have a
chance he would say yeah let's just turn
the board and i would be so happy to be
black exactly i i wanted to say as you
were talking that i really really do
like the move bishop h3 a great deal
uh trying to trade off that key defender
the bishop on g2
to make that trade would be
greatly strategically
in
black's favor
so the move bishop h1 well expected
on the other hand makes a really bad
impression as well because it's sort of
like this bishop on h3 is actually
pretty darn good
and a lot of a lot to be said peter
to for playing h5 h4
and try and get an initiative going on
the king site for black
yeah that's
that's an option however if you go h5 i
might have the time of pushing dcd4 and
it would be some kind of a relief to to
be able to push this deep on because if
i advance it to to d5 then new dynamics
appear i mean i perfectly get what you
are saying that black seems to be very
fast also after h4 but
having
having the black pieces and being in
such a comfortable
situation i feel like something like
bishop g4 would be a very natural way to
to try to stop d4 but as we see during
the game actually bishop g4 had been
played by hikaru and dcd4 had been
anyway played by magnus he just has to
free himself he has to open up the d
file at all costs to to get some counter
chances
absolutely and uh bishop g4 very natural
move as well issuing uh h5h4 style
attacks uh pinning the knight
maybe presenting opportunities for queen
f5
and queen h5 but here uh
capturing the pawn is doubt doubtlessly
a relief
for white but having said that you know
a pawns upon peter i mean i'm a member
of the
of the pond grubbers
and the president of the pawn grubbers
association
uh
why can't i take a pawn
yeah i know that you are the president i
know
definitely one has the feeling that this
is a poisoned pawn however the
absolutely thematic way of punishing it
does not seem to work because luke di
for quindy for knight d5 is made by
queen c5
and you are protecting on c7
so
this is not
not the way to go but simply after night
before even if i just remove my bishop
without any specific
all these
tactics are looming in the air
and hikaru said you know what i'm not
interested about this pawn you are
trying to get rid of it i gonna take it
when i feel like taking it
and
hikaru chose a very
nice positional strategical move bishop
before because let's just imagine
black gets a chance of trading this
bishop for the night and occupying the
d5 square that's exactly what he would
need
and i don't think that magnus can afford
this he has to do something against this
idea
exactly and behind this move there's
also a tactical sequence
uh peter and it might go a d5 the
desirable d5 would run into bishop takes
c3
pawn takes c6
and queen takes d1 whoops
once that knight on c3 got captured the
rook on d1
wasn't protected by the minor ps
and
uh
black winds
yeah however okay if after d5 you take
on cci definitely going to capture it
back the only question
what is the most efficient capture
and
d5 had been played by magnus
uh-huh okay so we're about to see bishop
takes c3 i do believe and
after bishop takes c3
uh peter again this knight on g4 is
still in
in a pin too
so it doesn't
make it that
much easier to take advantage of the
knight being on d5 so shall we imagine
bishop c3 queen c395 queen c5 as a
continuation or do you like somewhere
else to go with the queen
well maybe i would love to go somewhere
else but i don't see where
yeah and and there are good arguments
for queen c5 yeah because if i manage to
provoke some b6 then maybe i'm gonna go
queen b5 and you lose on your weakened
your uh
light squares right yeah we are seeing
bishop takes is the queen takes easy on
the board knight takes d5 also right
and queen c4
queen c4
okay uh
it makes perfect sense because now white
is threatening to take luke takes d5
because then uh this little tactics
maybe magnus feels like thanks to this
he gains one half little tempo which is
very important form for him to
coordinate his forces
exactly
well that threat
strikes me as so good
that i would deal with it by retreating
my bishop to e6 uh peter
i think a lot of uh six players in our
audience
also i'm feeling relieved yeah that this
agreed agreed that is uh you do get that
sense of relief but again um
setting the table it's really the simple
folks
madness is going to have to win this
game
to stay in the set we believe because he
could potentially win on demand with
black a much harder ask
so
he's got to win this game peter
yeah he needs to win but i think right
now the most important thing is to
forget about the result of this game
because the game is so complex and
magnus is again done to five minutes
what he needs are what he needs is
making good moves and then finally what
comes out of it comes out of it because
if he cares too much about the result it
will not end
any any good i mean he will be done on
time he might lose this game and match
the set would be
that would be lost uh he he needs to
focus because black is for sure
perfectly fine on the other hand i also
feel like uh magnus can maybe live with
this position uh compared to what he had
a few moves back
okay fair enough knight d4 on the board
um earlier uh black also had the option
of taking the knight on c6 and the
knight on f3 off the board when he could
have captured on d4 with the knight and
i thought hikara made the right decision
as long as the knight stays on f3 the
bishop on h1 its view is blocked so this
move knight d4 makes perfect logic and
after for example knight takes d4 i can
imagine
the rook capturing just so that this
rook on a1 can quickly enter the game
hikaru has played
intriguingly the move bishop
f7
[Music]
was that your first choice peter it
certainly wasn't mine
yeah no not at all i mean
basically bishop f7 almost indicates for
me like
hikaru
is thinking too much about the result
right now because he needs he wants
safety but can i just take on c6 and if
queen takes e6 do i have queen g for
check is that an option
absolutely uh go for that pawn on g7 by
all means
and by the way i mean uh
taking on c6 i have to play queen take
c6
and and we do see knight takes c6 on the
board peter so
i think this bishop f7
uh i've been louding uh ikaru and i
think he just saw in karu like
slam his hands on the table is it to say
darn it
uh what am i thinking this bishop f7
might have been like
the first time you've seen a a mistake i
mean just a a flat out mistake because
he's missed queen g4 peter he has missed
queen g4 yeah exactly that's exactly
what i was saying that uh maybe he
simply thought like okay i understand my
opponent has compensation so let me just
play bishop f7 and knight c6 queen c6
take stakes might will have anyway
wonderful compensation but enough only
for draw and this suits me perfectly
fine and then you just make this move
and then you tell yourself oh my god
what did i do because you immediately
spot queen g4 check and this is not what
we are seeing magnus is back in the
match
absolutely
a huge
huge turnaround that moved bishop f7 i
mean
it looked really artificial it felt
wrong and
it was a
blunder a a mistake
now the question is
can
magnus capitalize
uh i
i have to apologize to being therein but
i felt most severely that in his match
with magnus carlsen ding really failed
to capitalize on his opportunities
um will
magnus be able to by the way uh magnus
actually has five minutes this might be
magnus's moment i mean
to to right
how do you say rise to the occasion when
you have to win
uh on demand which is so difficult and
you accomplish it
uh it really sends a very positive
signal to yourself you say okay i
i can do this
and it really blows the wind out of the
sails of your opponent this would
this is a huge uh
peter
yeah i mean absolutely and the whole
point is that
why it's also very difficult enough for
hikaru to to face this situation simply
that the opening has gone so much in his
favor he had been so in control
and
having even
be ahead on the scoreboard so everything
seemed to have gone his way usually
people say like you should never think
about the score of the match
but
i believe there was maybe a moment when
hikaru saw like okay i'm leading now
even here i'm better maybe i can finish
this this match right here and from my
experience i know that even in the blitz
game whenever i feel like aha this is
the position i can't lose
even if i want exactly at that moment
when these thoughts crossed my mind i
already made the mistake and i'm losing
great it's uh it's it's very very
interesting and uh yeah now we see also
hikaru is very very angry with himself
because
uh
simply now
he's losing a pawn not just losing
because the pawn
material will become but he is his
structure will be spoiled and all of a
sudden fights two bishops on the long
diagonals
are doing incredible jobs so practically
speaking this is looking very very bad
for hikaru exactly and one of the things
that oh gosh they have such an
incredible skill set these world
champions the gary kasparovs the anatoly
karpovs the vladimir kramniks
well the magnus carlsens
when they spoil a position
they have this
skill set of surviving
and man they just you know grit down and
they they tough it out
okay let's try to tough it out a little
bit here for hikaru imagine queen
d7 queen takes g7 what else
uh what you said about my king side
structure is absolutely true i'm really
angry but let me say that i've got one
good thing going for me in the positions
the knight on d5 let me forward it
let me just
say okay fortify it c7 c6 it's a
ridiculous move i know
but how could magnus
uh push his advantage peter i i'm trying
to set a trap i hope i haven't set a
trap for myself
the the trap i wanted to set was bishop
takes f6
rook g8 and i think you got your hand
caught in the cookie jar there a little
yeah but uh
i mean simply the point is that look at
the time situation i mean hika is down
to one and a half minutes and it's clear
that he's completely shocked and very
very angry with himself and yeah
this is the moment when uh
when all these factors together the
position deteriorating plus all your
emotions
combined is making it very very hard but
of course the top players as you as you
mentioned all these super
guys and world champions legends and so
on
throughout their career they had been
incredibly strong
adjusting very quickly to the situation
that even if they were completely lost
and they are all of a sudden winning
they will not think about this that aha
i was lost so let's be satisfied that
i'm escaping with the draw they will
immediately jump on that
moment and make the best out of that
so i'm pretty sure that he could
put up hell of a resistance on the other
hand if magnus gets the confidence out
of this game
and
he he comes down and we start to see
magnus playing like he can
then hika who might regret this uh
dismiss
really very much because he he awakened
the beast in magnus well exactly and you
know just while you were talking peter
i was forcefully reminded of an
interview we had
with magnus after his match with
dingleren
where he was explaining to tanya he
really did not like his position one bit
and he expected in one particular
position of the sicilian
for ding to play the move knight
b3
when in magnus's words he felt he was
lost
ding didn't play the move knight e3 ding
played the move a283 and instantly
magnus left on his opportunity and said
bishop takes a3 and bang bang bang bang
bang the game was over so he went from
yeah i know i'm lost
to
oh here's my chance and bang i play for
the win now
it was quite a dramatic turnaround
yeah we are seeing now stabilizing moves
i mean black had kicked the queen away
with luke g8 queen h6 queen f5 a very
nice move pin f5 because now black kind
of signals that i want to get my counter
play with knight knight f4 going
somewhere so magnus made the very
natural prophylactic move bringing back
that bishop from h1 uh to g2 threatening
bishop hd
pin
a reminder yeah bishop http
i like very very much because getting
ready for the pin
and also taking control of the f4 square
just in case for any night
sacrifices and now we are seeing things
are developing very fast the players
after rook d4
uh hika who played luke the eighth queen
d2 the white queen comes back that was
another purpose behind luke d4 that now
white gets harmony and after c6 the move
bc b4 had been played and hika who plays
queen h5
almost instantly
a very clever move because b4 white gets
b4 b5 in you have to bother white and
right h5 black statens to enter with the
look to e2 and white has to deal with
this threat
exactly
again i mean hikaru
it's so so difficult you talk about hey
how do i get better
as a chess player you're going to have a
lot of challenges
uh when you play chess and one of them
is keeping calm
keeping your nerves and at the same time
stop beating yourself uh you know a
moment ago ikaru was arguably you know
right at the finish line all he needed
it was a draw and he blundered uh you're
gonna blunder and the point is after
you've made your blunder how are you
going to play uh are you going to put up
resistance or are you going to fold and
lose very badly and here we're seeing
that hikaru is putting up resistance
that little queen h5 by the way i
thought b4 was great uh white was ready
to you know
turn on the um the jets uh the attacking
jets i mean
and somehow queen h5 really took away
the because trading everything that
wasn't what what magnus wanted to do
peter
exactly i mean this queen h5 was very
very strong and already this the whole
sequence of
queen f5 luke d8 c6 i mean just shows uh
why hika is so strong in in this format
because i mean being shocked and
being long time he he went all the way
down to one and a half minutes even 124
if i'm not getting it wrong
however then he collected himself
and
played i think very very strong moves
and certainly i mean
white wanted more than the sand game on
the other hand
white is better thanks to the two
bishops
but
there is also this psychology that
hikaru has saved yesterday already one
opposite colored bishop
possession being toned down against
magnus
and
maybe he can rely on this uh experience
trying to hold this position
wow uh
you know talk about gaining confidence
and momentum uh
a while ago there
i'm almost just
gifting magnus the entire point and
saying you know like the position was so
good for magnus he's just gonna clinch
and win
and if hikaru
just does somehow manage to save this
game
uh my prediction of hikaru victory is
looking really
awesomely good on point because that
would be
a remarkable save i mean it still looks
terrible i mean
i mean but
you know there there are times you begin
to think that you know
i'm getting close to saving uh a
position peter
yeah now we see the move queen b1
it's kind of an invitation to something
similar we had seen yesterday
because right okay
i mean don't get me wrong white has many
options and my first instinct is
definitely not to take this pawn because
i believe that even after something like
queen takes v1 bishop takes b1 a move
like gc g4 followed by king gc is a very
natural way of putting the pressure and
denying on the two bishops and claiming
that okay you have this structural
deficit but of course we have to mention
what happens after bishop takes d5 c
takes d5 bishop takes f6 because that's
a healthy pawn up and if white gets the
chance of playing g for king gc i
believe this should be winning so
everything comes down to the fact that
can black block block down these pawns
effectively with h5 for example after f
h5
fc bishop f5 right he's going down this
uh
pawns
and if black gets his king activated
then it should be a draw and magnus of
course says no thank you very much i'm
in a must-win situation i i don't want
to go for this end game
but the difference is uh after queen d2
i like this move very much by
hikaru bishop e4 i would have preferred
your line of play queen b1
bishop b1 g3 g4 preparing as you say
king g3
and relying upon the two bishops i see
that as a two result game uh for sure uh
after queen d2 bishop e4 it's not that
yeah hikaru is not trying is trying to
win or anything like oh but there was a
there was a trick
yeah that was bishop takes f6 which was
hanging in the air for for quite some
time but
i did not did not mention it because
here after bishop f6 knight f6 screen e5
check that was queen d6 that was the
that was the defense however after the
queen's
queens moved to b1 and the queen moved
to d2 all of a sudden after bishop e4
the strike bishop f6
kind of
seemed to work yeah bishop g to king g2
the main point is that after queen e4
check white has the move f3
exactly
whoa
uh i don't know bishop take i i i miss
bishop takes f6 that'd be perfectly
frank bishop f6 followed by queen f4
check and queen takes f6 snaring the
pawn a very nice tactic indeed um
i'm just
i'm
thinking hikaru missed it as well
and if he did
uh that would have been like you know
his second big mistake uh in this game
missing the queen g4 idea was mistake
number one
and allowing bishop takes f6 might be
mistake number two now having said that
he says okay desperate times call for
desperate measures right king b5 king a4
let me waltz in and take the pawn on a3
yeah i mean he has to rely on this i'm
pretty sure he did miss bishop takes f6
but the situation was such that because
it was down to one minute on the clock
the position which was so difficult to
to handle and the move bishop e4 was
played automatically because you felt
like if i'm not playing bishop e4 i
anyway gonna lose slowly because no way
with one minute on the clock i can save
this position with all these weaknesses
against magnus so he did blunder on the
other hand now this position is such
that he can go berserk because now he
has nothing to lose right
right
and and he goes for it the only problem
is that
he's facing magnus carson who
i think give another chance he will he
will not let it sleep
okay so
from
black's point of view
he's sitting there saying okay i need to
engineer some kind of a perpetual check
right and so
uh from from from black's point of view
he always wants to
be ready with a queen e4 check from
white's point of view white's got some
uh connected
some past pawns on the king side he
wants to play g4 and f4 and go go go but
he doesn't want to see knight f4 shaq
land on the position so something like a
bishop i was about to say something like
a bishop d6
as a prelude to pushing the pawns magnus
just said not necessary i'm just going
to go queen e6 peter
yeah i mean that's why exactly i was
highlighting that this bishop on c5 is
so nice because
queen e4 check would be very very
unpleasant however this bishop on c5
protects the f2 pawn and then white can
go to with the king to h2 and there is
no follow-up right magnus perfectly made
sense out of it after king takes ac
already with the move queenie e2
indicated that he wants to enter with
his queen target the c6 pawn if the pawn
on c6 falls then black will not have any
more this very nice
defense for the knight
and we are seeing developments are
coming up so queen d3 queen takes c6
king beasley had been played queen e6
queen c4 queen f5 played not knight
takes b4 on the board
okay so i think in all of this little
uh dancing that was going on
uh magnus was readying the move queen
bee one czech peter to try to keep uh
[Music]
some awkward things going on but oh
bishop that he just took
yeah he just took because he is taking
on h7 and he feels that the h pawn is
just uh way too fast
exactly
well that's very very
also white's king is very safe yeah on
age two
yeah
well it's it's really really nice when
you can you know it's a race where your
king is the one in safety
and uh
this strikes me as a win
but having said that do you
do you remember reading an article in
new and chess magazine about it was by
dr john nunn where it was queen and two
pawns versus queen
yes i know this h and g form but but
here i think the difference is gonna be
that he will queen the h pawn and
finally they will get queen g3 f2 pawns
against the queen and then it should be
easy win
yeah
did that article by john non shock you
as much as it did me i would have never
guessed that two connected past pawns
could
that there was a possibility of a
defense in fact
yeah you know when i first heard it i
even said that okay i understand it's a
computer though but still if you are
getting outplayed and you are two pawns
done then please just resign yeah i mean
that would be so much more fair know
than to rely on some computer defense
mathematics solution we are playing
chess we are not mathematicians so you
outgrew design that's it and i will
respect you big time
[Music]
well as ben larson said about a fellow
grand master he's very very good player
he resigns
those correctly are the openness we want
to face no exactly uh
somehow magnus did did a nice job he put
his queen in such a way
that he's supporting his advance he's
protecting f2 and he's keeping an eye on
the b-pawn
uh
very impressive
peter yeah very impressive indeed you
remember we talked about this bishop on
c5 which was so strong
defending the f2 pawn now the queen is
doing exactly the same effect and look
at this if black has to make a move like
queen b2 this is very very bad news yeah
because not only the white pawn is
advancing forward the black queen steps
in a way of his own pawn
this basically signals that
game over is
game over what we are witnessing here
very very very quickly indeed uh
the one blunder you don't want to make
as white you will curse yourself forever
and ever you don't want to blunder the
f2 pawn
yeah this is the soul of the possession
thanks to this the white king is feeling
so secure
and magnus plays king g2 just to please
yes sir justin please yes i'm not gonna
blunder this phone i know that it's
important and hikaru has resigned after
bc queen a7 check yeah
uh
wow
uh wow winning on demand peter is always
always tough
karu is probably cursing himself because
he sure came out of that opening with a
decent position
but
one mistake tanya was all magnus carlsen
needed
one mistake was all magnus carlsen
needed and that happened with bishop f7
like you pointed out and after that
there was just
no coming back and i think not just what
magnus also needed but also what magnus
carlsen's fans needed because uh it's
all about getting that one win yes and
this is the first win that magnus
carlsen has had in this final uh i think
a much needed one to get into the rhythm
of things and what a final it's been
absolutely on the edge of our seats
we've
we've just been treated to immense
action i think this format just brings
that out this dynamic play this
aggressive play and it's been inspiring
chess from these two players who are
truly
the best in the world when it comes to
shorter time formats to online blitz to
chess in general and the other thing
that's been very very inspiring has been
seeing the chess community come together
to support kiva's cause
of helping underserved businesses
entrepreneurs individuals uh which which
are in isolated communities to raise
money for them to help them come out of
this pandemic and it's uh it's been
amazing to see the contributions that
have come in from grand masters across
the world
who have supported this cause and we
received
we received uh
a big contribution from temu rajabov
grand master tamu rajabov of azerbaijan
shout out to him for giving out twelve
hundred dollars and he will be gifting
48 three-month memberships uh for his
youtube subscribers tamur has been
taking the youtube world by stong with
some amazing content and streams he's
just hilarious on them super instructive
chess definitely check that out and temu
coming coming on and and giving back to
the society back to the community and
back to his subscribers by gifting them
this premium membership and uh 48 of
them will receive three month membership
another reminder to all our viewers that
you can go premium and contribute but
you can also
gift premium memberships to whoever you
want to to kids in your country to
schools
around you and 50 and there's a 30 off
on premium membership currently and 50
of that will be given to kiva's cause of
helping the community come out better
and stronger from the pandemics so a big
shout out to all our grandmasters let's
get that let's get that up to on our
screen again because we've had some
amazing contributions from dingleran
five percent of his prize money will be
donated to the cause uh grand master
pleco has been very generous with his
contribution we've had vasilevanship
we've had pantala hari krishna and duda
all coming forward to support this
immense and this amazing uh campaign
that chess 24 is so proud to be part of
and a big shout out to tamur for uh for
his um
for his contribution and join the grand
masters be a part of this movement
improve your own chess but also help the
community and support chess support what
chess 24 does and support uh support
everyone around us to come out of this
very difficult time better and of course
that's not all the action because as we
know that we also have
an insanely incredibly insightful
course by the world champion himself
magnus carlson teaching us how are
endings done i think undoubtedly yes
peter we'll all agree that magnus is
probably one of the best end game
players of all times he's he's right up
there with with capoblanca with uh with
all these great endgame players and i
think in our generation
he has changed the entire trend of how
endings are played earlier i think if we
look back at the previous two decades a
lot of equal positions a lot of
seemingly non-dangerous positions
players would agree to a draw but magnus
shows the complexities in endgames how
to win those points that that half a
point how to save it how to win that
extra half point all in the course take
a look
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to
[Music]
[Applause]
begin you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah i know years later
yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
now
on
chessable.com there's also a 20-minute
free lesson that gives you an idea what
the course is about so definitely
definitely take a look at that and
there's a great deal on it as a 40 off
the inaugural price of this magnus
touch course
i think we all could do with a little
bit of magnus touch in our games
and yes because you're with us we got
something very interesting on twitter
for you
uh let's have that on the screen and
douglas griffin with grand master yasa
sarawan at the london tournament now yes
i looked at this photograph
yeah
that's
i mean
very very um handsome if i may say so
and i also can say so please
please i haven't changed at all
not one bit not one bit and also i i
don't know if all of you know about this
but here's a little secret
yes was
in cosmopolitan 8 1983 edition
the most sought-after bachelor
is that true yes that is quite true
and it was a remarkable
thing because it was
very very unexpected to begin with but
one of the things is i got like 2
000 letters
like i mean that sounds like a lot but
until you actually see
how much volume how much space 2 000
letters
take up
well let's just say it destroyed my
mailbox
and
my mother bless her heart she read every
single one and she would read someone
she would put down her reading glasses
and go shake her head
and then quickly read the next one
it was it was
these were all marriage proposals
well dating proposals yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was kind of i love it i
love it so in 18 1983 cosmopolitan's
bachelor of the month
uh ladies and gentlemen as uh
is uh of course
they're very very charming grand master
yeah sarawan yes i can just imagine uh
i don't know i mean look at that
photograph that's that's really
quite
quite hot
well yvette my wife she won my heart and
unfortunately that's the way it all
worked out
yeah that was those were the days my
friend
yes absolutely and let's also take a
look at the other conversations that we
had on twitter before we've got a couple
of minutes before the next game we had
partha writing in with hikaru is simply
unstoppable take stan magnus with the
black pieces again i don't see carlson
coming back from this this tweet did not
ate so well
this is god like chess now wonder he's
no wonder he's considered the best in
rapid and place i i really think that
hikaru
really messed up what happened in the
last game i think it was as peter was
saying it was that you know that seconds
of just maybe an oversight and over
confidence and you just you just blitz
out a move and obviously you give that
chance to magnus carlsen there's no
coming back from it a much needed win by
the world champion uh who was actually
struggling right out of the opening with
the black pieces hikaru looked so looked
like he's doing so well in in game in
game three as well uh but yes one
mistake and it all crumbles down so we
are going to be having the fourth and
the final game of the rapid in case it's
a tie we will move on to the blitz let's
move on to our next tweet
we also had levi
leviticus leviticus
i'm sorry if i'm not pronouncing that
correctly magnus is the goat he can come
back from this indeed he can and i think
he needed that one big win to feel that
rhythm again he's got it
and i am sure hikaru currently is just
kicking himself for playing this bishop
f7 move because what opening prep he had
in that game just with the black pieces
simply out prepared and
outclassed the world champion in the
opening phase only to blunder right
after with bishop f7 let's move on
we had we had prague writing in we've
never seen magnus down and desperate
like this doing the seemingly impossible
absolutely but we've got a we've got a
set in our hands now uh boys and girls
because the score is even magnus has
leveled the score
it's one and a half to one and a half
going into game four
and anything can happen uh and you're
absolutely right magnus carlsen has been
looking a little
the shelved so to say and we've seen
we've seen hikaru on his a-game i'm very
excited about the game coming up and
hikaru will be playing with the white
pieces so let's see what happens
great tactics hikaru but champion will
bounce back he probably needs just one
win to get in the red rhythm amit great
minds think alike i completely agree
with this i think a must must-needed win
by the world champion as we've been
talking about it to get back the rhythm
to feel that confidence again because so
far it's just been a hikaru nakamura
show but i would say one thing
you know
bishop f7 was a blunder it wasn't
exactly and of course the world champion
played flawlessly after that but we're
still to see a game where we feel that
you know what magnus dominated hikaru
but so far we've seen several of these
games from hikaru's side being the one
keeping the world champion on the ropes
let's move on we've got a few more
minutes
mayank writing in with hikaru is facing
technical difficulties the camera
situation is bad please just 24 look
into it and don't make him play while
he's distracted
so
this is i think we saw his camera switch
off a couple of times and uh we've had
the chess 2014 is on it but for
everybody's information it was actually
hikaru himself he was not even once
informed by the arbiters or disturbed or
distracted by the arbiters to fit the to
fix the camera i think he's having some
uh some issues with the usp it was
hikaru himself who wanted to fix it in
the middle of the game and uh when he
did that when he insisted on doing that
in fact the arbiters told him that don't
bother with it just focus on the game
and you can fix it during the break uh
and of course yes i completely agree
that these kind of things we've seen
issues like disconnections or these
these off-board things which can put you
off but in this case uh absolutely
hikaru was informed by the by the
arbiters but only when he himself went
to fix it all right let's move on to the
next one
and actually with that because we've got
only a couple more minutes and i see
we've got peter and yas with us let's
bring them into the conversation
peter so last rapid game of the day
hikaru playing with the black pieces
he's messed up in the last round with
the move like bishop f7 what are your
predictions for uh
one are we gonna see d4 by the world
champion and now we're gonna see a
repeat of the kind of openings that
we've been seeing so far and two
how does
one recover knowing that they had a good
start in the opening but then made a
blunder
yeah i think uh thank you tanya and one
of the thing i want to speak about that
what we have seen in the second game
right that hikaru took the cynical
approach thinking that okay i have one
with the black pieces now let's put the
pressure on magnus by simply forcing it
over the white pieces if this strategy
works perfectly and it was about to work
out perfectly because hikaru had a very
nice opening very nice position but then
suddenly things escalate and like he
lost it now he's facing this situation
that maybe i should have not done this
you know and
those are the thoughts that you should
not let yourself get into during the
match
but after losing this third game it's
not just bishop f7 but connected with
the second game that maybe my strategy
was not right
these are the
demons
hikaru has to deal with na uh having
said that he carries the white pieces in
the fourth game so basically he this he
can decide what he wants from this match
because if he wants then he can just
play
very solidly with white and basically
make sure that he gets a draw and then
he has the blitz play-off which he might
feel like it suits him perfectly but i
believe that magnus feels like he got a
second life for today and we will be
seeing a completely different magnus
from now on
i'll just add to that peter that
in
the game that uh game two that
that hikaru was white he played one e4
move that we expected a move that he's
consistently played throughout the match
and
pretty much as we guessed it we didn't
see a sicilian by magnus rather we saw
him willingness to play at berlin so
with that in mind uh hikaru for this
fourth in deciding game of rapid chess
what should he play e4 is probably
expecting and his team is probably
preparing for berlin
yeah and e4 on the board by the way yep
e4 on the board
so in case of a berlin one of the things
that i'm seeing a lot of peter
is this early bishop takes c6 and d2 d3
because the
the the berlin ending has withstood the
test of time
yeah absolutely and don't be fooled this
is the way how things are going that
the game only starts once both players
make their first move and we had seen
only e4 for some while now magnus had
followed it up with e5
and we see third move knight f6 so
another berlin coming
exactly and uh
again this is where i kind of got a
little bit of a presumptuous
presumptuous a little bit ahead of
myself what i mean what i meant to say
was like bishop takes c6 d take c c6 d2
d3 as again uh no big breakthroughs for
white in the berlin ending peter
yeah but look at this i'm seeing the
same variation oh my goodness
the same variation is game four
yeah so hikaru is taking it
really cynical that he just doesn't want
to to play with the white pieces
wow
this is shocking
on the camera just laughing that off i
mean he he can't
he can't believe it he's like dude
you're white
[Music]
that's exactly what he's laughing about
dude you're white tanya
okay i
cynically suggested before
the first game of the match in the first
day
that hikaru would most likely be happy
with the 2-2 tie throughout the rapid
chest and to push the match into the
blitz chest very hard to get two points
out of four games against world champion
and rapid but that in a sense
he is feeling himself incredibly
confident in blitz but to do it in this
way tanya i don't know lisa leaves a bad
taste
yes yes and i think uh i think it comes
down to what does hikaru have in mind
for the blitz
i think we've seen him have some strong
prep is he just holding on to that when
the time from when the time gets shorter
on the clock because we've seen magnus
carlsen in this final struggle a little
bit with the clock handling and hikaru
has been very strong with the black
pieces so is this an approach a
pre-decided approach in the match uh
whatever it is magnus carlsen found it
extremely
amusing and
peter your thoughts on this approach of
just of bo of two white games just
ending like this
yeah i'm i'm not liking it you know i
understand this
match strategy and so on but what i
don't like why i don't like is that the
psychological advantage might be
shifting towards magnus because it
signals little bit from hikaru that yes
i'm perfectly satisfied with my black on
the other hand i'm not really ready to
to take any risk with the white pieces
okay here this is a very special
situation because uh hikaru might have
felt like okay
i just lost this third game it was kind
of a shock uh let's just settle down and
let's play like magnus also used to like
often uh two games instead of one to
decide the match outcome
but having done twice the same i
perfectly understand
magnus's reaction of of laughing because
i mean what is this i mean you are not
expecting this and uh
yeah will be very interesting again if
hikaru goes on to win the blitz playoff
then everybody will say yes it's correct
it was the right decision but imagine
things going wrong then everybody will
say that aha no of course you shouldn't
have done this and from now on magnus is
the one who is taking over the
initiative in this match
and you know what peter i agree with you
that hikaru lost the last round so to
stabilize things you're like you know
what i want to neutralize this game get
my thoughts together get get my nerves
in control i get that but then how do
you explain what he did in round two as
well because he had just won a game with
the black pieces and and exactly the
same thing
and uh yes i think it's a very
surprising approach because one thing's
clear this is not out of any fear of
playing the world champion because
hikaru has shown that he's been he's
been taking the the match head on
going for the most complex variations so
it's it's not any kind of fear but i i'm
really interested i i think it just
comes down to his confidence of
that you know what i am ready to play
blitz i'm ready to go shorter on the
clock i'm playing faster than you i'm
seeing tactics quicker than you uh i'm
better prepared than you i'm more i'm
well more well rested than you are let's
take this in a shorter time format and
we are going to be seeing
more action very very soon we'll be back
really quickly
but let's take a look at all the
exciting stuff that's happening in the
chess world and with all the educational
and instructive
uh
courses that we've got going have a look
at what magnus has for us ladies and
gentlemen please take your seats
the show is about to begin
[Music]
[Applause]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah no years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help underserved
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tools final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
you look at farmers in the rural areas
of tanzania and uganda the way that they
farm is very manual labor intensive and
they can't afford to buy equipment
outright and so we're focused on raising
the level of income by selling
productive use equipment with financing
[Music]
foreign
what
[Music]
ladies ladies and gentlemen please take
your seats the show is about to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah i know years later
yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
so if you want to improve your end game
definitely go on
chessable.com and check out the magnus
touch where he gives all his insights on
how to improve and become really good at
a very very critical part of the game
the endings which a lot of us overlook a
lot of us don't understand how complex
they are and so many points to be gained
over there learn from the best learned
from the world champion it's live on
chessable.com uh there's a great offer
going on so have a look at that and i am
still just reeling from the excitement
that we've had today so the score is
level it's 2-2 we're about to kick off
the blitz portion of it and the blitz
portion of the match today uh
it's
it's just
it's just amazing to see how how the
match develop here we can see that zero
one is actually the set lead that hikaru
nakamura has from winning his day one
but today's score is two two and we've
got the blitz coming up it's really
incredible to see see how the day panned
out today we had two insane games one
where hikaru came on top with the black
pieces he's chosen to play absolutely
aggressively with the black pieces today
even in the second black game that he
had he was doing so well out of the
opening and a slight mess up with bishop
f7 gave the game away and then two with
the white pieces i mean knowing that you
know you're
you're sort of in form and in shape
we've been discussing this that
is it wise to
to do this to just say that you know
what let's just take this to the blitz
and i'm okay giving out on the advantage
of um
of the white pieces and at the end of it
i think yes it comes down to how blitz
is going to go we've seen the world
champion himself do this at uh with in
his match against fabiano caruana i
remember the game 12 where in fact with
with the black pieces magnus was doing
really well in that position
and uh he just agreed for a draw really
quickly
went into the tie breaks and smashed his
way in the rapid portion and became the
world champion and then came out saying
you know what i knew what i was doing a
lot of people were criticizing that
approach of game 12
but it's all about
um about the end of it if hikaru
believes that's where his best chance is
that's what he's going for so yes what
do you what do you think about this
approach from hikaru today
well tanya as you just described it a
rather cynical one and i remember that
exactly the same thing also in the new
york world championship match with
sergey karayakan where uh magnus himself
did the exact same thing he gave up the
advantage of the white pieces and the
12th and deciding game went to tie
breaks one very easily i think peter
said it really well
that if
if hikara wins
this set
by winning the two blitz games and he's
a genius he did exactly everything
perfect
uh if he loses
this set of games uh in the blitz
everybody will say well why did you give
up the white pieces dude and
and it really is going to come down to
that
to that way of looking at it right peter
i mean you're a genius if you win if you
don't well you're a goat
yeah exactly but also there's another
thing i want to mention about the format
i mean why i'm loving this format and i
think it's great because actually these
draws don't take away anything from the
match because the tension is in fact
growing i mean we are about to see
two amazing blitz games that's what i
believe i mean from the two
very best blitz players in the world so
actually the spectators are in for a
treat
of course chess wise we would love to
have seen more quality from these two
games exactly because we know what these
two guys are capable of
but i'm pretty sure we will be
compensated for it in this two blitz
games and another little question i
don't know tanya do you know who will
pick the color for the magedon if it
gets to the armageddon today
uh if it does get to the armageddon uh
we are going to have magnus carlsen
picking the color but we are going to
confirm on that because magnus did
qualify for the fin and you have a
confirmation that in fact magnus picks
the color because he qualified into the
finals due to a tournament win while
hikaru qualified into the finals based
on his cumulative score throughout the
event only because magnus won multiple
events uh we do have liftoff and it's
blitz so let's get straight to the
action
thank you tanya and uh d4
and knight f3 uh
inviting a london peter
yeah that's what i also fed like but all
of a sudden magnus after
knight fc d5 chose the move c4 if you
would have asked me i would have told
you no way magnus gonna play c4 here if
he already started with knight fc he
will not play bishop f4 and if he served
him so well against dinglin
but
magnus wants to make thing mix things up
and look at this bishop g5 dtx e4 e4
this is not something you see very often
especially yeah exactly especially the
bit usually you see the knight on c3 as
in their previous games where we've been
seeing that b5 variation and now with
the bishop on g5 are we getting
a proper uh
well vienna uh
mine uh peter i i must say sadly my
openings are not up to date
uh
what's the latest and greatest going on
in this line
i'm not completely sure myself the the
point is that yeah this fourth move
bishop g5 that magnus used is actually a
move trying to avoid
certain type of uh
things and after dtx dtx4 this move of
e4 is is very very rare so i believe
magnus must have some specific idea in
mind the question which player will turn
out to be better prepared here or who
will feel the position better later on
okay
intriguing uh
again you know like this pawn on e5
right like that's somehow a kind of a
magical pawn you
you kick away the knight on f6 and it
lends itself very nicely to king side
attacks even the bishop sacrifice with
bishop h7 and so forth bon on d4 still
on the board peter um
yeah okay like has this extra pawn this
pawn doesn't matter that much because
white can take it almost any given
moment
but i believe that he first wants to
make sure that he he gets some
some strategic clumps and magnus is
going for it he first
puts his knight on d6 makes good use of
this e5 pawn and he says that if this
pawn on d4 is not running away then let
me try to grab it in the best possible
moment
fair enough uh it's a
very strong statement the night on d6
versus the knight on a6 no contest
whatsoever the knight on a6 is
out of the game now having said that
um
oh i
no i was uh i was trying to uh do
something that uh
never mind queen d7 peter
yeah queen d7 now the question is can
white capture with the queen on d4 and
follow it up with luke d1 stabilizing
the knight yeah and magnus does queen
takes d4 because if white gets queen
takes d4 okay d1 in and stabilizes
knight on d6 then it looks like a very
nice advantage to play with
exactly i'm just getting a little bit
scared about this knight on a6 maybe
knight c7 to d5
and one day later down the game i'll be
able to play knight c8 and to scare away
the knight on d6 but for the moment but
it's the knight on
a6 that i find disturbing icarus says
i've got no such concerns yes sir don't
worry yourself
okay he has brought his knight back to
c7 and saying okay four verses four two
versus two
uh all i'm looking for is to make a nice
solid draw can he do it peter
yeah it's it's a big question because uh
black does have this d5 square and as
you rightly pointed out if black gets
knight d5 and
also challenges the knight from ca from
d6 with knight c8
then
white will also have
trouble maintaining his initiative so
white has to be very precise magnus
played the move queen e4
hinting gets some knight g5 idea so
it's very interesting
to see what's how black we react because
you are also pinned but maybe this pin
is not important because queen takes d1
is possible so if you can make a move h6
and h6 played by hikaru then you have to
make sure that the knight does not come
to g5 absolutely i didn't want to have
anything to do with knight g5 whatsoever
h7h6 certainly has gotten my vote queen
b7
nothing the the the door closes after
knight d5
so the knight on f3 jumps into the fray
peter
yeah knight d4 knight cd5 f4 played
basically
both sides both sides are trying to
strengthen their position
really the the real question is
uh what will happen with this knight on
d6 i mean let's just imagine that black
exchanges the knights from e7 for the
knight on d6 and suddenly we'll be
talking about that black has nothing to
worry about and knight c knight c8
played so magnus has to keep his knight
on d6 alive in if he wants to claim any
advantage
exactly and that was my thought too uh
peter you kind of get this
um
duel
of the knight on d5 versus the knight on
d6 now that move f4
to my way of thinking that was a big
decision i mean it did
you know strengthen the pawn on e5 no
question it it does prepare f4 f5 in an
aggressive manner but it does open up
it lifts the kimono a little bit on
white's own king and did you like that
decision peter
you know we are supposed to be many
thousand kilometers far away but when f4
was played i immediately felt your vibes
yeah
this f4 is not approved by yourself by
no means i mean why do you do this why
not just g3 and stabilize and uh
and look at this magnus is taking his
time and if
this is a blitz game this is a blitz
game now magnus is one minute almost
yeah he's exactly at this moment one
full minute behind on the clock wow
wow uh but did to be clear peter did you
like the decision f4
no i i mean intuitively i fully agree
with you okay
now having said that you said that white
has to maintain the knight on d6
uh guess what peter uh the commentator's
curse
he traded
and
he traded but after a lot of hesitation
because i think he realized that this f4
was not really
connected with the position and he
wanted to make sense out of it and after
knight c8 queen c8 he made the move f5
that he wants to justify his f4 move
right making of
virtue out of necessity f4 f5
again these players are
putting the pressure on one another what
i mean by that is this move f5 i mean
both players
uh
you know these are very very consequent
choices that they're making and it's
like they're challenging each other
tactically and strategically in every
way they can
quite frankly um and what would happen
peter if
black was to take on on f5 i'm assuming
knight takes f5 and say queen e6
and just saying okay i'm solid or
haven't yes but rook takes right
yes and queen take that's the one don't
take the queen looked at the queen and
allowed 97 check that would be
embarrassing
the royal fork
but yeah i was trying to just uh
ask the question queen e6 and
or is white justified in all of his king
side attacking attempts
yeah but somehow after ef5 one has the
feeling there are way too many tactics
maybe more than one would like for a
blitz game
took his time played the move queen c5
but what you mentioned i said i think
was perfectly right i mean the players
make such difficult choices and they
constantly make such choices that the
open end should never get his comfort
zone because believe me as as you put it
perfectly if you give the comfort to any
of these players in the blitz game they
will make 20 moves in 10 seconds and put
the pressure on you increase the
position and you will not have any
practical chance and they are
challenging each other they don't want
to back down they don't want to give
anything for the opponent exactly now
we've seen a trade on e6 peter queen c5
does have this
very annoying pin on the night
uh
and the challenge is for for magnus he's
got to get rid of that black queen he
can't just allow it to stay there he
played rook c1 and was met by
knight f6 hoping to play queen takes d4
and liquidate into
uh what hikaru knows as a drawn rook and
pawn end game
yeah probably and this is this here
this hikaru had to force the when he
chose queen c5 because queen c5 was by
no means obligatory
and uh
yeah we are going along this line ft g7
but is this such an easy draw
uh
that was my question for you i don't
know if it's such an easy draw i was
going to play rook f6 and after for
example rook c7 i wanted to play rook d2
and i was trying to play for activity
uh with the rooks
uh
[Music]
yeah and hikaru did play the move duke
f6 yeah
yeah
it's it's a nice
it shows class it shows class
well in the immortal words of elvis
presley thank you very much
[Laughter]
welcome welcome i mean okay if i have
too much respect for luke f6 i just
gonna play rookie two and say that this
is a blitz game and i understand it's
zero but maybe i can go gc king g2 no
magnus says i gonna go look c7
and then after rook d2
then he's gonna play g3
wow this is very interesting
okay
that was not
to be expected that is for sure so his
idea is if you play rook f2 rook takes
e6
and you don't have the automatic draw
which you're showing thanks to the rook
on e6 defending the e2 square as well as
attacking the e8 square
so
hikaru said great i'll just munch upon
yeah he took on b2 but then magnus also
took on a7 and look f7 yeah this is the
professional way because
you understood that finally this g7 pawn
is is way too powerful in some positions
what pawn is upon but
it looks very drawish
yes
so the way they reached this look f7
king yesterday rookie 6 king g7 the v7
king g6
this definitely it looks like it's
heading for draw two versus one or three
versus two
uh in rook endings most especially
are drawn and in this case uh since the
pawn is already on b4 and it's rather
dangerous
oh well if i'm gonna if i'm able to
maintain my control of the second rank
definitely this is the professional way
of making a draw by hiccaro i was about
to say
it was no rush to play b3 but this is
this is absolutely rock solid safe don't
be
persuaded that uh that there's any real
chances here yeah
i mean uh ikaro would have to make a
howler
uh a move
a blunder of such great proportions
that
you could hear the cries in the next
county
uh howler this is heading for draw peter
yeah i mean there is just
nothing nothing else than those
is imaginable here
right of course maybe magnus will play a
little bit because okay why not
the only
weakness on h5
it was a little bit surprising for me
that hikaru chose this h5 plan a tempo i
mean with the pawn on h6 you are also
perfectly solid but it also just signals
the confidence that okay i know that
this is a dead draw i don't care and
look at this he carries up one and a
half i mean he's back to one minute 36
on the clock
and
i think this is just
question of time when they will call it
a day
yeah while we're watching them go
through the motions of this drawn
rook and pawn end game i have this very
nice story i was playing
a match against vasil yvonne chuck
and the first game i was white i had
some advantage he sensed the the the the
position
uh called for uh transposing into a rook
and
i just uh caught myself peter because
okay
i was about to say there's rook h6
coming uh and
we ended up in a rook and pawning game
rook and four pawns versus rook and
three the game was a draw and the second
game is black i sacrificed a rook
somehow i got the initiative i was
rooking for versus rooker iii
and then we had a tie break a pair of
rapid games and i said to vaseline ivan
chuck i said basil if i get rook and
four versus rook and three i'm claiming
a draw by three match game repetition
got the same position of four
somehow
hikaru's king got to e4
and it it caused me pause uh peter i
thought the king was perfectly safe on
g6 and g7 what's it doing on e4
yeah that's
i mean it wasn't exactly planned but uh
i think eco was just playing too quickly
and he was
earlier relying on this king g6 king g7
setup but suddenly he activated his king
to f5 and let these
things happen but of course it's just
that they're also right yeah and now the
players exchanged the rooks we are about
to witness the stan mate yeah there you
have it
so a draw with black
by hicaro in this first pair
of blitz games what he desperately
wanted to do in game three of the rapids
he managed to do in in in the first
blitz game and as uh tanya mentioned
coming into the into these blitz games
um should the next game be drawn we'll
play one armageddon and magnus will have
the choice of which color he would like
for the armageddon overall your take of
this
your overall sense of this blitz game uh
peter
well i think no dear surprises
hikaru had been very solid with the
black pieces all the way
but i see tanya is here so let's hear
what she has to say
yes peter i i think i agree with you on
that that this was quite a well-played
blitz game from both sides and the
balance was kept throughout uh
uh
probably
the fact that hikaru played with the
black pieces and was able to neutralize
and not get into too much trouble is
something that the hikaru fans are
definitely happy about and now it brings
us to the fact that we have no idea what
hikaru has prepared with the white
pieces because we've not seen any of
that so perhaps in the upcoming blitz
hikari does have the advantage that
whatever he plays team magnus has not
had a chance to really look at it to go
into it and find something uh peter do
you think that might have a role and in
some ways now in retrospect justifies um
hikaru's actions during the rapid with
with going for an early draw
i mean i'm certainly very curious to see
what hikaru has in mind what he has in
store for us with the white pieces so
far we haven't seen any of it today
uh i don't know if it was all part of
the plan because after all hikaru could
have never known that he is gonna win
with the black pieces so i'm pretty sure
that he had some ideas ready for for his
white games
he did not show it yet and yes this is
this is some kind of a little advantage
but on the other end i think by now
magnus feels also very confident playing
with the black pieces so let's see
what's going to happen
and
we had yan steak on the way um hikaru
has handled the games today with the
white pieces saying that finally the
berlin repetition by gm hikaru nice prep
all right shots fired by yan nepamyashi
uh
but absolutely i think uh i think it's
gonna be interesting to see
what opening prep does hikaru have in
mind i think we're gonna see a berlin
for sure and i
do not
i don't believe that hikaru would be
very pleased about doing the same thing
that he's done in the rapid because that
means we go into the armageddon with
magnus having to pick the colors not a
situation not a dream situation so now
with the white pieces he definitely has
to show what he's got up his sleeves and
talking about preparation uh
we all need preparation we all need to
be good at our openings and if it's
something and i know in online blitz and
playing against players that it's you
know openings matter so much because
coming out of it you want to have a good
middle game position and otherwise as
vishyanan puts it himself opening prep
is critical because without that you
don't get a good middle game
if you're struggling with openings or
with the middle game or with endgame
definitely consider going premium
because chess 24 has a 30 off on premium
membership currently as well as 50 of
all premium membership goes into our
support kiva campaign which aims at
helping and providing funds to to
businesses to to enterprises to
entrepreneurs who have been hit by the
pandemic support chess support chess 24
support the community and talking about
improving your own openings and
improving your own preps there are some
fabulous video courses by the world
champion himself uh on the stonewall
there are there is uh yeah grandmaster
yan gustav sun's course
there's grandma world champ from a world
champion wishianan's course some amazing
uh sources and resources out there to
improve your own play so a great time to
invest in your own chess education with
a great 30 off and also of course
supporting the community by doing that
we've got 30 seconds before the second
liftoff uh yes what do you think do you
do you think that hikaru will be as
confident a confident taking the match
into the armageddon as he was taking it
into the blitz
no i'm not sure he's going to be as
confident about the armageddon he's
definitely the one of the most confident
players about his blitz there that
exists
uh with white i suspect he does have
some prep prepared for the berlin we're
about to find out tanya and peter
they're off
[Music]
and that was it
bishop takes c6 this is what i spoke
about
uh
during the rapids peter i know that this
has been
the
battleground
for the top players uh who have been
trying to avoid the berlin endgame peter
yeah but you know to to tell you the
truth i was about to correct you in the
live broadcast but then we went to the
different subjects that the bishop takes
c6 is never played in this position
because first fight plays dc black plays
bishop c5 and then white takes bishop
takes c6 you are right you are i mean
and now i'm completely sure that team
hikaru is listening to our broadcast you
know i mean
the move bishop takes c6 i think it's
maybe a novelty what is this
you're absolutely right peter they do
wait with the move d3 bishop c5 then
capture and then later the bishop moves
back to d6 did mag didn't not magnus bit
did hikaru
[Laughter]
under a tempo we're about to find out
what's your take on the current
situation i don't know if how they got
here was the right thing but they are
here
yeah they are here and this is one of
the sharpest way of playing all these
anti-berlin positions and yeah black did
save a tempo on bishop d6 compared to
bishop c5 bishop d6 on the other hand
hikaru maybe wanted to make sure that he
gets this structure and
he just wanted to be sure that he gets
this structure
probably believing that he can handle
this very nicely in a in a blitz game
but i do
believe that also if someone is a very
very big expert from the black side this
is magnus carson i mean uh the knight on
e6 and this is a typical magnus set up
with going bishop g4 quickly he does it
also in the other line
and freeing the way for his knight
i think
magnus should be very happy and look at
the clock situation as well
okay and when i see the move g2 g4 it
does signal to me that white is going to
go queen side because again you know
he's pushed the pawn shield in front of
the king side so queenside castling by
both play by both players uh peter
yeah it's it's very typical
the knight on f5 compensates for the
for the lack of the pair of bishops and
hikaru breaks the center with dc d4
i don't know
if
i don't believe that white can hope for
anything more than equality here but
maybe already he could do fed like okay
let me get a safe position to play
magnus was showing too much confident he
was too pleased i don't want to risk in
this game and now basically black is
forced to take on f5
i believe and then we will see
yeah bishop f5
played and he takes f5 okay this is this
glasses things up
that definitely is a weird recapture to
my eyes i thought he was gonna capture
with the g pawn play something like f3
and try to make hay down the g file
capturing away it's almost like a you
know
uh
what is it a rui lopez exchange
variation in reverse somehow it's weird
there's double f pawns in the position
peter
yeah exactly you got it perfectly right
with this exchange will open stuff
i'm a little bit uh
surprised myself about this ef5 on the
other hand the structure after ef5 is
much more stable for white and magnus
does try to to break the structure he
went with h5
right away interesting uh the reason why
he might have wanted to capture with the
e pawn is to one day put a rook on e6 i
can imagine he wants to play bishop f4
and rookie six and round rock having
said that he immediately doubled on the
d file did he karu
so scratch that
as a reason but this move does invite
rookie 4 peter
yeah but on the other hand uh
i think 27 was the the natural move
white went for queen a4 yeah the big
question is
does uh hikaru really believe that he
can target the black king was that maybe
his main point and uh by playing b6
magnus shows respect because the move a6
would look much more natural but then
suddenly something like rookie four and
somewhere queen d4 and hitting at a7
would have been awkward exactly so we do
have b6 and that move does invite queen
c6
um
i don't know are things getting tricky
or not maybe
maybe well he did play queen c6 i was
about to say should we fall back on the
rookie four idea to try to plant the
rook on e6 no hikaru is happy putting
his queen on c6 to my mind uh peter that
queen is just too strong it's got to go
queen e8
yeah queen eight is the very natural
move i mean you can't really thoroughly
this queen on c6
for too long on the other end after 28
yeah no magnus played bishop e5 wow this
is very nice judgment because after luke
d7
there is some takes takes queen before
counter play on the b2 pawn right
goes look d7 black can just take
and ignore it
and since c7 is protected i have to play
bishop c1 and i am hanging the pawn on
g4
in this particular variation doesn't
look like rook d7's
playable peter no it actually happened
so i'm sorry it happened
oops
okay well
uh he car was
squinting he's he appears to be looking
into the position but
i don't see what he what's attracted to
hit
what's attractive about this position to
him peter help me out i'm looking at two
pawns hanging b2 and g4 and i'm not
liking it for hikaru
yeah that's true on the other hand i
mean maybe vehicle was fooled by the
illusion that the rook on d7 and queen
c6 seem to be so powerful hitting
attacking black king hitting at c7 pawn
but this bishop on e5 is doing
incredible job protecting the c7 pawn
and also targeting b2
and uh yeah did he want to play bishop
defense sorry he did he did it i wanted
to ask you did he want to play bishop d2
bishop d4 yes he did and he has played
at peter yeah he played bishop d4
and this is ultra sharp
because he's a rpm queenie one check
likely that magnus has at least a draw
luckily for white the h1 square is
protected by the queen so does it you
know the rook cannot rush in
yeah
but but somehow one has the feeling
that something is loose with uh with
white's position magnus played the move
bishop d6
bishop d6 wow this is this is a nice
move because the queen still protects d6
so you cannot sacrifice it i target the
bishop on d4
exactly and uh i don't know hika who
played the move queen e4 and queen a for
all oh yo yo this is
under
oh
oh oh oh
with the double threat of the rook and
there you see hikaru
he's just oh he smacked himself in the
head
the queen
a4
nasty nasty and look at that
cheshire like smile
that's uh that magnus produced
yeah what do they leave for magnus of
course they are winning this set
he has tied the match by winning the set
and like you said uh peter
if you know you gave up you know hikaru
gave up two draws with white pieces
without any effort whatsoever
if it had worked it was a brilliant
strategy if not
you're going to get enormous criticism
yeah i mean you get criticism and you
are also criticizing yourself because
i don't think that hikaru cares so much
what people say because he's playing
this match he's playing the world's best
player if he felt like this is the right
strategy but of course you want to
justify this strategy and he was very
close to justifying it because the game
see he had a perfect position
uh this game was a very tough fight i
mean i did not really and it was too
complex i couldn't really understand
them was the turning point it felt like
all these things with with queen c6 and
luke d7 was maybe misjudged by hikaru it
looked too tempting and in blitz game
you of course the temptation is there
you blitz it out and all of a sudden
after queen before practically speaking
it looked like uh black has all the
chances
exactly if you go back to that position
for just a moment before queen b4 was
played
this was an in in
in a sense if you just go back just a
little bit uh
peter this this is such a tempting trap
you know you you invite your your
opponent to play rook d7 dominating the
seventh rank and then queen b4 it seems
almost like a breakaway goal
in football tanya what a turnaround
and what is
what a break for magnus
what a break and we do have the world
champion with us uh magnus
congratulations
yeah thank you
that entire set had us on the edge of
our seats first tell us your first
thoughts getting out of this with queen
f4 in the end
yeah um
yeah that was uh
[Music]
that was a pleasant feeling
um
apart from that
obviously the first game was was uh a
disaster
and in the third game i just
i was probably
more or less lost at some point so
um
obviously i needed some breaks to to get
back in the match
magnus we're going to ask you about the
critical moments in the game but also um
after a very difficult set one coming
into today what were the adjustments
that you made
um well first of all
i decided to play a lot more solidly
with black
sometimes
magnus can you adjust your mic because
there's a little bit i can't hear you
yeah okay um
no as i said i tried to play a bit more
solidly as white
sorry as black
but i
i suppose
um
yeah i suppose the the opening choice in
the first game today and probably also
the third
um
they they weren't they weren't perfect
in the sense that
they were
pretty um pretty difficult to
play
talking about your opening choices with
the black pieces going in for the berlin
uh your thoughts on
hikaru hikaru's approach
when he had the white pieces in the
rapid potion
uh i thought it was reasonable
um
so
i mean he'd gotten great chances twice
counter attacking as black so
uh why wouldn't he
wouldn't he sort of um
yeah i mean i it's it's not an obvious
choice but i don't think it's it's
support choice and
i think in general he he has a match
strategy and he knows what he's doing
fair enough and we but we did see you
especially after the fourth game that
you were quite amused by the second
quick draw what was what was going on in
your mind then no i thought it was just
funny that we played the same game twice
um but i mean i'm no stranger to forcing
a draw that in that particular situation
myself
so it was
i mean it was not a
smile of
bemusement it was rather a smile of
amusement
all right and yeah we were in fact
talking about this because we saw you
have that approach in your match against
karjakin where you're white and also
with fabi going into the tie breaks and
uh
shortening your 12th game um
but
it's always like in hindsight right
because it seemed to work out then for
you but right now it didn't work out for
hikaru so that's kind of hard to deal
with
i guess so um
but
you know
people
make the decision that they think give
them the best
chance to to win and then then you live
with the consequences you cannot base
um you cannot base everything on on on
the results
um and so i i think
obviously it's it's still going to sting
but i think he felt that that was the
right decision and he probably still
does
all right and
magnus um
after after the way things went
yesterday
uh you know you said you made some
opening adjustments there was this whole
talk about also
perhaps playing positions which were
which was something that hikaru was
doing better you know these complex
messy positions did you feel that as
well when you decided to go for these
more solid uh this more solid approach
no but the thing is in the very first
white game i went for something very
messy and um
[Music]
to play good chess i just
uh
i i don't know i think i think you you
you got to be able to to do both play um
complicated positions and more
more solid ones it was just that
probably the one i had in the first game
was a little bit too difficult to figure
out over the board
right and uh with that um are you do you
have a little more time to just go
through some critical moments with peta
and yes because we've we were just
absolutely amazed at the games that
happen if you could just show us some of
the lines yeah sure i can i can do that
yes
you have questions about the game well
let let me jump in right away just first
of all congratulations magnus for tying
up the match
i wanted to
draw your attention to something that
tanya showed us which was really
remarkable i'm sure your team is going
to show it to you well peter if you
could show
in the game that magnus lost that he
actually had
a perpetual
at the position where he
he played the move e5 e6 and it
apparently turned out magnus that that
move right here gave away what could
have been a draw okay you ready for an
alien chest variation
yes bring it on okay are you ready rook
c1
like what
peter uh take it away from here
yeah well to be honest i mean
as i said usually you need to play a
correspondence game in order to
understand and appreciate
what's happening behind luke c1 tanya
was the one who checked it with the
computer and she had shown us some
brilliant variations i felt like the
most difficult part is that you probably
did not even believe anymore that you
you really have a draw here
well the thing is i i
if i'd calculated a bit more i probably
would have gone for something like this
because my thinking in playing e6 is
that i was going to pick up both the
pawns
and if i pick up both the pawns then you
know i go f4 f5 and i felt that there
were considerable practical chances but
he plays accurately and he doesn't let
me pick up the pawn but
uh i'm curious to see you continue the
line
after luxi one one of the main lines had
been b2
mike my first guess was what happens if
black just goes like rook hc8 that was
my human reaction but
tanya do you have it no but are you just
continue queen of three right
yes after eight after rook c8 then you
go queen of three and there is no escape
queen g4 yeah queen goes to g4
you go to f5 whenever you go to last
rank of course you you take the rook
exactly so
there's queen g5 queen d7 king g6
there's queen e6 and the queen is not um
sorry the king is not escaping you can
bring the queen to g7 as well like king
aj
h7 queen
queen g7 right but it doesn't help
exactly exactly that's a perpetual as
well uh take us through the line with b2
instead peter
yes but here after you feel that you
have this luxe six check you already
feel like there should be something i
mean
i'm pretty sure magnus would have been
very pleased with this
well i like the perpetual that you
showed
as tanya where the rook was
uh checking on d6 and c6 and b6 yes this
is the one
yeah the stunning line of course
that was stunning
yeah
yeah magnus we were all disappointed
that you didn't even see this much
oh i mean um as i said i just had the
wrong approach at this point i thought
as
i said i thought i'm picking up both the
pawns and i i should have decent
practical chances
like to be honest i wasn't even that
upset when he went king f5
instead of uh
instead of taking the draw because i
thought
that there would be serious practical
practical chances
it's funny that you should feel that way
uh
magnus because another thing that
that tanya surprises with king f5
queen takes d5 peter if you will for
just a moment queen e7
tanya said that the computer's
evaluation after queen
takes b3
what black is up an entire rook was only
plus one so it's interesting that you
thought
that even though you're down a rook you
had plenty of play for uh for it
yeah um well i mean there are serious
parallels to my game against hussman
um if
i mean you
you can have that as a homework for
the next set because that's
um there are really a lot of a lot of
the same themes uh from against hussman
2008 and i was back in that game it was
the exact same material balance
um
uh queen and rook white had queen and
rook against queen and two brooks and
um
it was there was just an amazing amount
of tricks and
um
i remember after the
after the game at the closing ceremony
um
some of the some of the guys like uh
gelfand husman they showed me
um a few of the
the the most amazing lines of chess i've
ever seen so so so check that that out
but having that in mind um
it's no it's no shock for me that queen
b3
um is um
[Music]
here white white can play on i i just
chose the wrong way with with e6
probably e6 is also conceptually wrong
because i just want to go f4 f5 without
committing the pawn 36 so that that was
kind of poor
all right and peter maybe you have also
some questions thoughts to share with
magnus
well i mean okay i could ask uh that
what was the reason because
we felt like this knight e7 was a very
nice flexible move finally moving away
the knight from d5 and vacating this
square so any piece can occupy it and
after queen d2 queen d5 it seemed like
from your time management that it came
as a shock how did you feel about this
moment
yeah um
yeah queen d5 i mean i have just
i was literally
working through these lines a minute
before the game and somehow queen b5 i
couldn't couldn't remember and i
just found it too difficult to figure
out
my first thought was that since it was
not mentioned in the notes it's probably
not very good um
but like to refute it over the board in
in 10 minutes is pretty hard
um and yeah the the the line i went for
was just
a tad unrealistic
uh unfortunately
um
i i just underestimated his 22nd move c5
maybe he has others as well but
this particular
line uh i'd underestimated i just
thought
c5 bishop h5 right i should have
should have something but in fact the
queen is doing a great job from a3
protecting his
uh his king but i mean as as you can see
in the game i still managed to put up a
pretty nice fight here but
um yeah that was um
that was a bit too too ambitious
and what about game number three magnus
because something really went wrong in
the opening and we were really concerned
that you are facing a must win situation
how you gonna deal with it and
the position got completely out of
control what's what is your take on that
um no i mean i just i just mix things up
in the opening again and um
um yeah if you'd gone
h5 on move 15
uh
[Music]
i mean i thought
that would have been
that would have been much over
[Music]
it was not serious move i mean jose was
asking me what do you do peter against
h5 i told me don't ask me this question
yeah i mean i thought
i thought i was completely completely
lost after this move so
that was um
yeah i definitely messed up messed up
before that but the thing is like after
bishop chief for
d4 i i was already feeling
a whole lot better now
now it's it's it's a real fight and
after
after he goes bishop b4 takes already my
practical chances are excellent um
since i mean
there's quite a transformation that's
happened in a few moves now all my
pieces are are playing and i have an
initiative i
managed finally to give up the d-pawn
which i so desperately wanted to get rid
of and
it's all it's all good
all right and uh one thing about this
last blitz game because you know it
during the broadcast when you first time
played the move knight f6 yasaya
mentioned the move that there is this
concept of taking bishop takes c6 and
then playing dc and i everything went so
quickly i couldn't tell you that sorry
yasir it's supposed to be first dc and
bishop c5 bishop takes c6 so what did
you think about facing bishop takes e6
in the blitz game
um
yeah i think
he was designed to confuse
but i mean realistically the positions
are not going to be that different so if
he's playing for some concept instead of
uh concrete lines i guess it doesn't
matter that much and to be fair i think
he got a somewhat better position at
some point anyway so it wasn't
um
but
i wouldn't necessarily recommend it for
for classical
okay thank you magnus i will hand it
back to tanya and yasir
magnus before we before we let you go
and get some rest for tomorrow's match
we did receive a question for you from
hand shoot and he says karpov stated
that playing a set is more tiring than
playing one classical game do you agree
what is more exhausting a best of seven
or straight classical days uh
and because this is i think this is an
important question because we've been
discussing mental fatigue a lot at the
very end of the tour what's your take on
this
um
i think uh purely in terms of uh
of playing
um
[Music]
uh four classical games it's definitely
more stressful than than one
uh sorry for rapid games is definitely
more stressful than one classical
um
probably it's a little bit more
stressful preparing for classical than
than rapid but i would say overall it's
it's more stressful to to play these um
these match formats with a with a lot of
games per day
you think the difference is that in a
classical format it's towards the very
end that you know you start questions of
stamina and energy come into play while
here every day you're dealing with that
uh yeah i think um
i think that's definitely the case both
um
both to some extent physical but mostly
like just mental stamina
it's really um
in these high pressure moments it's
really hard to
um to stand attention
all right well thank you so much uh for
today magnus and all your insight and we
will see you tomorrow congratulations
once again on today's win thanks a lot
all right so the world champion magnus
carlson levels the score by winning
today's set it did not start really well
for him uh that first game yes peter had
us all uh wondering if
this was again going to be a hikaru
nakamura day but magnus carlsen got that
one chance in game three
and i have to say the blitz was
brilliantly played by both players
especially the first blitz game but the
second one it always felt that magnus
was doing well from the start
yeah i was gonna say i mean this is a
guy who just
he takes advantage of his chances tanya
like no other right i mean uh
he in in that game where um
he uh
must win as white
and as he said he just felt that after
h7h5 he didn't like his position
whatsoever
but the moment he was able to sacrifice
upon and
and and and fight his way back into the
game getting his pieces active getting
more confident about what was going on
you know he
he got rid of his d-pawn all of his
pieces were working
and
it works out for him and
and it and it's amazing and we we we're
in awe
and again just as his ability to find
these chances for himself to take
advantage of them is is really
remarkable and then uh to beat hikaru
uh in blitz
okay that's a challenge and that's why
magnus is just something
extremely special
he's great in rapid he's great and
classical
and as we see he's pretty darn good in
blitz too peter
yeah i mean you know it was very
interesting for me that
this position i mean if i'm pretty sure
if he car would not have been in elite
like one and a half half in the match
situation i mean it's so much hikaru to
go h5h4 after white's king right so i do
feel like at this moment maybe
hikaru
saw too much about the result instead of
about the position
and his next couple of moves were aimed
to stabilize instead of using the
momentum yeah and i understand magnus
perfectly imagine after h5
there are all these clothes around your
king and you don't believe in your
position and you think that yeah you're
just going to be crushed
and suddenly you are given a
oops yeah bishop g4 d4 suddenly you are
given a chance of sacrificing the pawn
yourself opening things up relying on
the two bishops and you are back in the
game
uh this must have been a big relief for
magnus here and then things turned
practically completely in his favor
well as judith pogar would say tanya
magnus is back in business
yes i also know of a certain lawrence
friend who would say that as well and
indeed he is back in business uh
um or rather as they say in the business
he's in the business
and yes he is is we've got a match guys
again it's a
a best of seven but it's one to one and
this is what we were hoping for
uh
a a hard-fought match tanya
we have a fought match on our hands
indeed the score is one one definitely
hikaru nakamura regretting that bishop
f7 move because i think that was an
absolute turning point in the match
today as peter pointed out the opening
had gone so exceedingly well for hikaru
showing absolute a class prep here
fast on the clock everything under
control and then just one in accuracy
and uh like you said yes you know that's
all that magnus needs i cannot wait for
tomorrow it's been an inspiring day
seeing all this chess action that we've
had and of course
if you are inspired by all the chess
action that you're seeing in this 300
dollar magnus carlsen chester benefiting
kiva final the entire price fund in fact
it's been um it's uh it's by chess 24
and as you can see the winner takes a
hundred and forty thousand dollars while
uh the loser of this final is going to
go back with eighty thousand ding lyran
uh and daniel dubois had to settle for
40k it's been an amazing tour with so
much prize money to fight for clearly
the players are bringing their a game on
they are not holding back on prep they
are this is the biggest prize fun online
event the strongest online event of 2020
and it's all been done by chess24 and i
think we have been so fortunate to be
able to follow it with this amazing
lineup of chess experts chess analysts
chess commentators throughout the year
throughout the summer that we had so if
you want to consider supporting
everything that chess 24 does and
hopefully have more of such events in
the coming future and see more of this
kind of insane action
uh in the near future
definitely consider going premium
supporting chess 24 and there's a 30 off
on premium membership not only do you
invest in your own chess education not
only do you support everything that
chess 24 does but you also support see a
kiva's campaign and uh thereby help out
the communities that have been affected
by
kovid
and uh before we sign off let's quickly
take a look at some of the stuff that
caught our eye on twitter
chess legends writing in
chess legends uh reminds me of legends
of chess what an event that was that was
not a great gesture from hikaru i know
he rarely defeats magnus but playing for
a draw right from the opening shows the
clear difference between a champion and
the challenger magnus always plays for
the win chess lessons i get your point
but i have to i kind of disagree with
that and especially after listening to
magnus talk about it uh that you know
there is an approach and hikaru came
with an approach and you can always say
whether things are right or wrong in in
retrospect in hindsight we all felt that
you know he had the white pieces he
probably had to show more
but
he had he had an idea of how to handle
the match situation and he went for it
and this is what we've seen magnus do in
the past as well again of course we you
know personally of course it's a debate
that with the white pieces do you try do
you not try or do do you
follow what you want to do and i think
magnu hikaru just being the professional
he is just decided that i want to play
the blitz uh and being confident enough
in that took magnus on yes peter what is
your what is your take on this
especially after listening to
how magnus felt about
hikaru going for those quick draws with
the white pieces well i i will
definitely defer in this case tanya to
magnus and i'll agree with him
wholeheartedly
that it is an approach and it has
consequences and if if it had worked out
uh any car had won the blitz games it'd
be a different conversation but again
just as you were saying uh prior to the
match
you know uh hikaru's weighing the scales
where
where is my opponent stronger where do i
have my chances how can i best win the
match in my view where hikaru really
could win the match
is in the blitz so
you know if you were to ask hikaru look
in these sets of seven could would would
you agree to play two two two two two
each and every set you would say
absolutely this is where i can shine so
it was a strategy it didn't work today
but maybe it works tomorrow
[Music]
indeed um
and let's take a look at what else we
had on twitter
all right
before we go on to the next one uh of
course uh i have to say it's been a very
very exciting day of chess but uh yes
peter i think the other the other
amazing thing that we witnessed today
was also just the support that has been
coming in
uh for the kiva campaign by our by
by many grand masters just across the
world we had tingler in with five
percent of his prize money going into
the kiba campaign we had support from
grand master peter lecko
all these top players have actually
gifted memberships uh to students to to
kids to talents in their own vicinity in
their own community and by because you
can buy you can go premium yourself or
you can donate premium membership and
with that they have not only contributed
to the growth of our game but also to
the kiva campaign and a big shout out to
temu rajabov who the who contributed
twelve hundred dollars and he's going to
be giving up 48 uh three month
memberships to his youtube subscribers
big shout out to tamu's youtube channel
that has been entertaining all of us if
you haven't checked it out you are
definitely missing out on that uh lots
of lots of entertainment uh thank you
for that temura and thank you for your
amazing contribution as well
let's take a look at some of the other
tweets that we had
or perhaps uh let's wait on that let's
get
let's get peta's thoughts on tomorrow so
the score is level it's 1-1
peter we've seen as even magnus spoke
about it we saw in the first set a
different approach of going for the most
complex positions of going for
extremely aggressive positions and then
today he said he wanted to play solid
with the black pieces how do you think
what do you think is going to be the
approach by hikaru and by the world
champion going into the third set
yeah i think the very big
importance in today's matches that
i believe hikaru came to this match
against magnus knowing that he has to
show his absolute best because that's
the only way of beating magnus carson
and yesterday he played the perfect
match won the first set and i have the
feeling the regret hikaru might have
about today is not about these draws
with the white pieces but much more that
his strategy of playing a perfect match
he had a chance he had a chance in the
third
game to to win today's match as well
and uh
the the problem is that i feel
magnus is still far away from his very
best and uh hikaru must have felt like
okay while magnus is not in his best i
have to play brilliant and i should make
sure that magnus doesn't get a chance to
show his best during this match
but after winning this second set i
believe that maybe exactly this was
needed for magnus to
to turn the tables and calm down
completely just focus on his game
somehow understand exactly how he should
be treating this uh
fight against hikaru because he hikaru
had been an incredibly unpleasant
opponent in this first two sets for for
magnus but slowly maybe the initiative
might be shifting toward
magnus thanks to this uh important
victory today
absolutely peter an unpleasant opponent
for the world champion but i have to say
that's exactly what the world wants
because then we know we've got a real
fight as magnus carlsen has not had it
easy so far you know we've seen him
dominate the entire tour but here we see
a very informed in-shape hikaru nakamura
and you are completely on point peter
that uh we are yet to see that magnus
spark come in
to
uh
into play but what we do have is the
magnus touch for the end games
uh we have uh the world champion telling
us how to play endings with giving us
his insights on how to improve just
absolutely an incredible comprehensive
educational and a supremely entertaining
course by the world champion
take a look at
what that's about
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah i know years later
yeah
which is why whenever this game is
brought up online
so definitely take a look at that and
for now let's bring up the very last
conversations that caught our eye on
twitter we had gear writing in with i
see several comments that heading for a
quick draw with white has never ended
well i'm not sure carlson and karjakin
would agree with that i think madness
answered this uh the best uh himself
saying that there was an approach he
himself had it in the 2016 world
championship he did it in the 2018 world
championship in game 12 even though he
was black in that but he actually had a
better position where he decided not to
play on and just go directly for the tie
breaks um like we've been talking about
it's an approach you have it and you
just go for it and whatever the
consequences are you face that if things
had turned out for hikaru we would all
have been like that was an amazing
choice but things didn't turn out well
for hikaru and
it's uh still the thing that as a
professional he felt he had to do in
today's match and that's what he did
let's have the next one
we had the underrated guy writing in
which part of the game is your favorite
opening middle game end game uh i'm
gonna bring that up for our players when
we do have him have them next uh let's
ask yas and peter about this uh
guys what do you
which one do you enjoy playing the most
and which one do you enjoy training in
the most
well for me
it's really really easy uh sorry to put
it in this way uh tanya the end game
why because i really know what the heck
is going on
a lot of times in the openings i get
really confused and amazed by what i
think or bad moves but their computer
recommendations and middle games as
we've seen throughout the first two sets
of this final uh can get really crazed
but somehow i have this calm
collected understanding that in the end
game i know what i'm doing so that's my
answer how about you peter well my
answer is uh a little bit different
approach i mean i enjoy always the fact
that i'm having a nice position so if i
have a nice opening i love openings if i
have a nice middle game i'm feeling also
very happy and if i get to play a lovely
end game then i'm all for it um
but
i mean imagine the opposite scenario i
mean whenever you are having some
trouble somewhere then you just hate
that part
regarding the trainings of course
everybody knows that i'm a very big
opening expert so yeah one can easily
guess that
my main attention is uh focus on on the
openings but i think that's what usually
all the top guys are doing
all right
tanya what about you you gotta answer
that question too
i think if it comes to a part of the
game that i enjoy working on the most i
think it has to be middle game i think
just understanding different structures
different uh kinds of positions and how
to improving on tactics improving on
your positional understanding i just
find that very rich and very satisfying
i think as far as
i think my least favorite part is
preparing openings i find that i find
that absolutely torturous and the reason
for that is i have the worst memory on
the planet and i think uh
that's um because a lot of times you
have to actually just memorize moves and
have them in your head but that's always
a struggle for me
i do struggle with endgame so i should
definitely check out the magnus touch
and the magnus course on that uh
because i think with end game especially
with rook pawn endings yes i just feel
like every time i study them
and i see them the next time
i have no idea what i'm looking at like
it's such a it's so difficult to
understand the subtleties and it's crazy
because there are such few pieces on the
board but it's so complex and i just
feel like you have to keep revising and
returning to these uh theoretical end
games uh so to say
dude
well don't don't don't beat yourself up
too badly i still have these horrible
memories of your defeating anna zatonski
in a very clever rook and fun ending
which really cost america in the final
round
i'm still i'm still overcoming it you
know like i'm traumatized uh by your
victory in that uh
finally
the 2016 olympiad oh my god this uh any
reference to olympiads and
over-the-board chess these days just
makes me so emotional about getting back
to playing over the board but for now we
have all the online action and we'll be
back tomorrow with set three it's good
night for me uh to all of you uh thank
you yes thank you peter we'll see you
tomorrow thank you all good night
everyone
yeah thank you bye bye
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Applause]
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that
yeah years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
[Music]
you